Italy has offered Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg the use of the Coliseum for
their fight
please I don't know who may be out there
a higher power
whatever you are please all I ask is to
make that happen could you guys imagine
the Coliseum lights cameras the stage
Elon Musk Mark Zuckerberg that'd be the
greatest thing ever so uh yeah that's
we're going to talk about that and then
we got a bunch of news I guess it's news
Joe Biden is going to bypass the Supreme
Court rulings because you know he's
fairly corrupt but sure whatever
Michigan is making it a felony to use
the wrong pronouns what else is new and
in France there's a major Riot going on
Republican Congressman said that he
thinks alien ships may actually be from
A Lost Civilization hey it's a Friday
night but uh we're gonna get in all that
but before we get started my friends
we're gonna give a shout out to silence
do good check this out this is a comic
produced by one of the Tim cast members
if you go to Turkey robot.com
you can check out more excuse me and
support the silence do good comic we
have here their Indiegogo project for
silence do good time travel agent they
say what if America's most prolific
founding father found himself trapped
inside a VR program controlled by AI if
you want to support the uh uh the comic
again turkey robot.com salty Allen
Rhodes Charles noff special thanks to
you guys for being members and I wanted
to shout out the best image I've seen so
far
this right here is part of the comic and
clearly it's an allusion to Joe Biden
but the symbol of the authoritarian
regime is a red line with a blue line
going up jumping above the red line and
moving forward I thought that was
terribly clever terribly amazing so uh
special thanks for being to you guys for
being members turkey robot.com also
don't forget to go to timcast.com become
a member of support our work you can
click join us no members only show
tonight those are Monday through
Thursday but with your direct support
you helped make all of this possible we
got a couple cool people joining us
tonight so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends we got Alex Stein pimp
on a blimp let's go insane for the
Ukraine let's do it okay Claire is still
here hello I haven't left she just kept
being kidnapped here I had to eat sushi
and look at a skate park yes that was
fun so you admit it there's a skate park
it's there Hannah Clara is here oh hey
she's already talking hello sorry I'm
here to go from I'm a writer for
timcast.com hi everyone Ian croslin here
too I read that comic I like it silence
do good cool stuff man you guys did a
great job that's really interesting it's
intriguing for for like a six page
preempt that's really cool thanks
it's all done it's Kellen filling in
Friday for search uh and I just want to
say Happy Birthday Grimace so shout out
we love you Grimace R.I.P
his birthday but I think he died as well
let's uh let's jump into the first story
the only story that matters Mark
Zuckerberg and Elon Musk Italian
government offer fight like true
Gladiators at the Coliseum the ministry
of culture's office is in a statement
saying there have been no okay so
they're already writing on our parade
this because this this is the update
literally as of right now there has been
no formal contact from the ministry nor
any written document even to the news
appears uh tasty it is unfounded the
initial report was that an official from
the government of Italy contacted
Zuckerberg about staging a UFC fight
against Elon at the most legendary
Battleground in the world you know why I
think it's more likely they did make the
offer I think they're panicking and
they're saying no no we never we never
made this up no I think someone probably
did I think someone was like a
preliminary look if someone in Italy was
going to entertain the possibility the
first thing you got to do is figure out
if Elon and Zuckerberg would do it you
can't go to the government say hey let's
prepare the Coliseum for a UFC fight
we'll book them later no no the first
thing shows that go to Mark Zuckerberg
and say hey how would you feel about
fighting at the Coliseum Zuckerberg tell
somebody the story goes viral and it was
preliminary in the sense that you need
to know for sure they want to do it
before you make any moves to prepare for
it but uh what do you think Alex you
don't think they would just fake it for
the publicity and just say that that I
mean it's a possibility I just I don't
believe anything that I read in the news
so I think that they could just be you
think he's just lying about it I mean
yeah they're just trying to get some
cloud or I just want to believe it's
true tweeted it I know I want to believe
it she tweeted it Elon said there's a
high possibility the fight happens at
the Coliseum oh that's where it should
happen and as he says the most
entertaining outcome is the most likely
I highly agree that would be the most
entertaining outcome do you think elon's
just manifesting though like no one from
Italy was I don't think he needs to
manifest he probably actually he's a
huge believer in manifesting hey look I
was going to get a fighter Coliseum we
got a suite right here he said some
chance fight happens in Coliseum I told
you so we need to work on my endurance
it's a non-zero chance he said he needs
to work on his endurance yeah you know
Lex Friedman sparred with both these
guys Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg and
at the end of it all he said I love
these guys I had so much fun I want them
to to be sparring partners I don't want
them to actually fight because you know
you break Elon musk's brain that's a big
problem for a lot of people same with
Zuck so I kind of with Mark I I don't
even think it has to be like wet blanket
like it's it could be really great to
see Elon and Mark Spar and to see them
become friends and and work together for
the future I would I would agree I don't
think elon's Mom is too happy either if
you her tweet yeah do you think Elon
would consider a performance-enhancing
neural link to help him in the fight if
you hooked himself up to a computer to
give him an advantage his neural Net
versus Zuckerberg's meta net yeah I mean
somehow they both need to hook up to a
computer and fight in the metaverse and
then nobody gets hurt if you if you were
gonna do a boxing match and you could
somehow have like an augmented chip or
system so that you could read your
opponent's algorithm like you could see
their muscle you could see what part of
their muscles were getting hot how fast
parts of their body were moving would
you augment well yeah I mean I think the
future you know we joke about this a lot
in but I really I'm a conspiracy
theorist and with tin foil hat wearing
but I do believe that that is the future
that they're going to tell people to
plug into a computer some sort of
Vanilla Sky fake world you're going to
live in some sort of pod but on Earth
they're gonna say you only live till 70
years but in this pod you're gonna live
for a thousand years because more than
that or more than that no no no but I
mean more than just being Immortal
they're gonna say in the Pod you can fly
yeah oh yeah
in the quarterback of the Dallas Cowboys
what was that you identify as a carrot
in the Pod you can be a carrot exactly
right and the Pod you are a carrot
carrot World Imagine somebody being like
I just feel like I was born in the wrong
body I'm a carrot and then they plug you
in and you go into a fake world where
every other person is an AI generated
NPC and their carrots and you live in a
world where everyone's a carrot
that'd be better than what's happening
right now to be honest
that's why they're making the world so
bad metaverse carrot they want you to
have such a terrible life you know just
be totally basically destitute can't
make any money so that your only option
is that you live in this computer where
you're a millionaire it's a long-term
marketing yes I mean is is cipher wrong
when he's eating the steak and he's like
I don't care that's the best part of the
movie really yeah think about it because
like do you really want to go back to
the Matrix I probably would I mean if
you're on a ship with a bunch of dudes
like pooping you know in a bucket in a
bucket you know that movie is terrible
or you can go to the fake metaverse
where you can just eat steak and be but
once you know dude once you know it's
like
knowing that your body is in some metal
tank you know in a pod being pumped full
of bugs no steak whatever taste is good
you'd be like constantly like uh you
know what I mean well I don't know my
dreams feel real sometimes you've had a
dream that felt real
well I'm just saying in the in the
metaverse or whatever when you're
plugged in your dreams could feel like
it's real I mean I've had sex in a dream
and it felt real I mean I've I mean I've
eaten in a dream it seemed like I was
eating food every time I tried punching
in a dream my hands would move real slow
running away you're like you're worse
reading but you know what I still have
do you guys have stress dreams I have a
dream and it's recurring I don't have it
as much anymore where I wake up in the
middle of the night and it's a friend
calling me and he's like why aren't you
at the exam right now and I get I have
that I have that regularly like I don't
I don't have that because regular dreams
about missing exams no it was like I
always had this dream when I was in
college that I had signed up for a class
and then somehow forgotten about it and
on the last day of semester you remember
you have to go take a final yeah or it's
like it's definitely like something you
have forgotten that sense is always
it'll be like a football game like I'll
be in high school and be like oh I got a
football game tonight and I can't get
there it's weird yeah I have dreams like
that but it's more like I missed the
show yeah seriously yeah that's exactly
I'll have a dream where it's like where
where our car broke down in DC and it's
like we're not gonna make get back in
time what do we do and I'm like wow I'm
gonna miss it mine where I'd be uh have
a play that night and I didn't know my
lines I forgot to memorize my lines but
I'm all going on stage in the dream and
it's like yeah I have this recurring
nightmare where Alex Stein is boxing a
guy and that's terrifying that's a scary
dream yeah me but uh yeah you're gonna
be is that what's going on what's going
on unboxing yes guys everybody July 22nd
Misfits 008 you're looking at the newest
Logan Paul wannabe Primetime Alex sign
I'm going head-to-head against Modine in
a no holds bar well there are rules so
it's there are whatever
bars are rules unboxing
foxy got no head gear and uh it's three
two minute rounds in Modine you better
watch out dog because I'm gonna bring
the Thunder and the lightning I was
noticing you're looking a little thin I
am thank you Tim Tim's been very nice to
me and uh two that girl last week
There's a I'm telling you I've never
seen more sushi in my life I thought I
was in Japan when I walked in you have a
refrigerator full of why do you have so
much Sushi it's Friday I know but that
you got a lot I mean there's a lot
there's a platter people work here we
get two trays for like 30 people
normally like the scraps we throw to the
chickens but the chickens are in an
emergency holding facility to do the air
quality which is improved so nothing can
come home yeah the air quality is
totally safe now it rained I'm very
happy this morning I was inhaling that
oxygen stuff really works yeah I got a
question about about everybody getting
put in pods you guys were talking about
that earlier so you said they think like
they want people in pods just because
like they want you to at least I've
talked about this they want they want to
like control people make sure they don't
go crazy put them in the Pod do you
think that they people really believe
that if we were happy and we started
pairing up and having families and like
communities that that would actually be
a bad thing is there like a thought that
that would be bad somehow yes because
they hate you like what is it they hate
what do you think they hate you are the
carbon they are trying to reduce you're
a peasant
well if they want to eradicate if you're
trying like imagine this imagine you
have roommates who keep pooping on the
floor you would like to not have those
roommates correct that's true yes
they're like look we're over here trying
to worship Malik and you know create a
One World Currency and this guy Ian
cross is making these videos about
abolishing the Federal Reserve that's a
problem for us
at the end but it's it set it on the
Georgia Guidestones they want to reduce
the population
it said maintain a population under 500
million
it didn't say reduce oh I see what
you're saying yes but there's a reason
why they want a small population because
they just want the elites and then
basically like a housekeeping staff so
they just don't want there to be like
two classes and there's that's kind of
where we're going there is no middle
class anymore and that's why I think
people have lost the American dream
because nobody can afford a single
family home and if you look at like the
price of a single family home in the 60s
to now I mean it's just it's impossible
our parents had
a lot easier when it comes to it came to
the American dream the US government and
big Pharma and tech companies love
depressed people because who's going to
get into these pods like if you have
friends a community and a family why
would you be like I need to live in
virtual reality whereas if you don't
like your life you're lonely or
depressed of course you would get into
the Pod you're the first to go but they
like everyone here
they don't like liberals I maintain this
position
what do you mean
that
when we're talking about powerful
wealthy Elites and people who run
corporations yeah if you went to the
average CEO and said which group of
people would you rather have rural
conservatives or Urban liberals they'd
say rural conservatives hands down
unquestionably
do you think that I I would say it is
fairly obvious for a lot of reasons the
first
think about climate change big problems
but it's all stemming from cities think
about all the problems Democrats talk
about with overpopulated prisons cities
then think about the fact that
conservatives don't protest but they
don't say that they're killing cows in
Ireland sure sure it's not absolute but
what I'm saying is conservatives don't
protest they live on Little Farms and
mind their own business the amount of
pollution produced by the average
conservative is substantially lower than
produced by the average liberal so if
you look at everything these Global
leads are talking about all the problems
they're experiencing it is dense cities
not rural populations so I always put I
always put it like this if Alex if a
person come up to you and said Alex have
you considered aborting your children
what would you like do you think that
person's your friend or do you think
they hate you
how would you consider sterilizing your
kid just just wondering like come on
yeah I think you're a psycho I mean
that's not a person who likes you yes so
when you have these Democrat politicians
and people like Bill Gates or whatever
being like I think people should be
allowed to remove their children and
abortion should be available for all of
these people it's like I kind of think
you hate them and you're trying to have
less of them you know what I mean yeah
but to be fair did you see that Lindsey
Graham where he was talking to zielinski
and how he was so happy about more dead
Russians
that means more dead Russians good so
he's I guess conservative but it doesn't
matter the right side or the left side
They Don't Care About Us they don't care
about their this is my point this is my
point the way I describe it is you've
got a chicken coop the chickens keep
pooping in their water you go into the
chicken coop and you say Hey you
chickens you stop pooping in your water
the next day you come outside half the
chickens are still pooping in the water
the other half have stopped which
chickens do you eat yeah the water
pooping ones the ones that won't listen
that keep polluting and destroying
everything so when I look at when you go
to West Virginia and you drive around
what do you find people have solar
panels people have septic systems which
are very self-regular regulating in a
lot of ways you've got to get them
pumped but if done right it could be you
don't you might not have to so
the pollution produced in rural areas
dissipates in cities it concentrates and
then what do you see the advocacy for in
blue States things that
stop liberals from having kids so it may
be they really don't care about us at
all and all they're saying is let's
enact policies that result in less
people but those policies
disproportionately reduce liberal
populations yes yes but I also see a
disdain from the Elites for people who
are self-sufficient and they continue to
pass legislation that is contrary to
people being self-sufficient there's a
huge just for you know you can't even
collect rain water for God's sake in
many states
there's there's
not blue cities those are around like
West like you look at Red States and
they're doing the opposite of that no
even in red States there's still a lot
of restrictions to our restrictions that
I don't agree with I think they have a
dis we are winning a lot of flyover
states and the people there I think they
do have it to stay informed we have
absolutely one on two way the expansion
of constitutional carry is unprecedented
the expansion of shell issue in recent
years yeah yeah I mean the past 30 years
you know in the 80s you couldn't get
guns and it wasn't until 2008 the
Supreme Court I think it was Heller it
was a Heller versus DC when they were
like actually it is an individual right
to keeping bear arms you know outside of
your home and stuff like that so
we're winning on that all that in New
York you struggle in in blue dense blue
areas life is a struggle they're
releasing criminals into the cities
there's an increase in violent crime
people are getting pushed in front of
trains you come out to West Virginia you
got no problems
crime is down it's lower than the
national average I haven't seen one
crackhead since I've been here from New
York and they do have drug problems in
West Virginia you know they do have
opiate problems but I didn't know this I
actually thought crime was was fairly
bad here and then uh we had I think was
Riley Moore talking about it I pulled up
the stats below average crime in West
Virginia Statewide and all jurisdictions
is below average so if you want to live
in New York where they're releasing
criminals and justifying it where
they're allowing lewd and lascivious
performances advocating for people to
terminate their kids or sterilize their
kids those things all result in the
destruction of that population meanwhile
in red States they're doing things that
allow the individual to thrive and and
to flourish so they can't even have
pizza why oh I know right why is this
agenda is it agenda 2030 they're trying
to create like Mega Forest they're
trying to like
re-naturalize a large segments of Earth
and not have humans go there like no
more human Footprints in these big
forested areas they want people away
from like the out the
whatever you would call this the the
rural areas and they want to pack people
into these mega cities I don't know if
I'm not speaking for everybody but yeah
but but a 15-minute city is not it's not
a mega City it's a small pod City yeah
where everything's 15 minutes away yeah
where everyone's like hospital every
your grocery store everything you would
need a 15-minute city is not going to be
20 million people in one circular City
it's going to be small pod cities all
over the place
the reason why that's bad too is it's
easier to shut down when it's a small
City well exactly yeah well I don't
trust these people at all anyway so it
doesn't really matter what to wrap it
all up with a nice little bow who they
like and don't like they do bad things
dude Rural Life is nice I'm really
starting to love it well you know it's
funny because everybody talks about
Texas I remember Ian you were just like
oh you know Texas and Joe Rogan people
are moving there and the reason why
Texas is good is because it's for fat
people there's like a CVS in every
corner there's a McDonald's and so it's
like yeah I love the real life too but I
kind of like that I can just like go to
the Walmart or buy my tuck friendly
bathing suit at Target and my Big Mac
okay all within half mile I want to pull
up this tweet from the DeSantis war room
and uh okay my let's pull this up my
personal opinion is slightly negative on
this Suite I think it is cringe I think
DeSantis team is correct and they
deserve so on on the political point of
this video they deserve the credit their
criticisms are fair but man you guys
ready for this let's go they tweeted to
wrap up pride month let's hear from the
politician who did more than any other
Republican to celebrate it here we go
how can you fix the audio yeah try it
now
nope wait I will do everything in my
town
to protect our LG ttq citizens but
Caitlyn Jenner were to walk into Trump
Tower and want to use the bathroom you
would be fine with her using any
bathroom she choose is that is correct
in the future can transgender women
compete in Miss Universe yes make
America great again
man it's growing on me
I cannot think of anything more
horrifying it really has shut down drag
just produced some of the harshest most
Draconian laws that literally threaten
trans existence congratulations Robert
Sanders mission accomplished you win
I can't do it
okay I I like the music I think the
point being made is correct I don't I am
not as critical As Trump for or you know
in the past when you held up the LGBT
flag and all that stuff he is not
talking about what we are currently
saying he was talking about other things
there are many people that we are
friends of and fans of that previously
did align themselves with the
traditional LGBT stuff and Trump I
believe was correct to be like hey those
people are good they're going to vote
for us what we're seeing now is very
very different does Samir move that I
think is wrong but Trump absolutely was
not as as harsh Rana Santos is
absolutely going after this in the
culture War more so than any other
leader
but the American Psycho bit and the Chad
meme stuff it's just it's it's too like
if they took that out and just showed
clips of DeSantis like pointing to the
press and like answering questions with
news articles I'd give it an A plus the
weird meme things is too much like I'm
with the turtle kids I like it I have a
preference for Trump over to Santos but
I I like this video I think it's good do
you like it sketchy yeah I like it over
the top yeah the music works for sure
yeah yeah they all need to show Brad
Pitt's face once they showed it twice
and American Psycho it was great yeah
the second shot of the cycle oh good I
just it's like is is he trying to align
himself with being a psychopath no it's
very gen Z so the Patrick Bateman the
American Psycho memes those are big on
Tick Tock and one shouldn't say so it's
very I I guess you're the one that stuck
with it but but that's that's my point
like Rhonda Santos is older than me why
is he like trying to like are the kids
gonna be like wow he's so cool we're not
going to vote for him anyways uh
statistically gen Z just doesn't turn
out but are you gen Z yeah you're gonna
vote for him right no would you would
you vote for him if it wasn't Trump
no really no who's on your who's your
top contenders right now I don't know I
don't know to be honest Trump would be
at
the moment what about Vivek I do like
Vivek a lot and um Robert F Kennedy Jr
RFK I love because he challenges the
system but he's still anti-2a yeah so
but I do I I will support him just
because I think he has an important
message he still is a Democrat so if you
leave Republican you're not gonna like
him yeah I was this this Trump stuff I
didn't know that Trump was all in on the
inviting see this is the thing if
someone had asked him are you okay with
letting a trans political movement
indoctrinate children into becoming
trans and having sex surgeries he
probably would have been like no like
what are you talking about of course
that's crazy so I don't think this is
stuff from back in 2015 yeah eight years
he didn't see it coming I mean remember
it whenever he debated Palin Joe Biden
was against gay marriage everyone's
opinion shifts over time especially if
they're they're uh political cohorts
change their opinion and I think we have
to give trouble out of credit when he
was talking in 2015 no one knew exactly
where it was going some people could
have predicted that we'd be selling uh
gender affirming bathing suits to
children Target but not a lot of people
friendly those are for adults it's just
gender affirming when it's for children
so what Ian said it's like listen I love
the pride flag because now I know if I'm
on like a street I know which are the
gay bars oh that's a gay bar so I think
you know that's good that we should have
pride Flags I'm not like against you
know canceling the pride flag but what
does a pride Flag symbolize is it the
only difference between me and a gay
person or a straight person a gay person
is their sexual preference so this flag
basically indicates your sexual
preference why does that need to be in a
school like that does that need to be on
a flag well I mean I listen you want to
have that on a flag go ahead you want to
do butt stuff and have a flag for it
actually go ahead but why are we going
to put it in the kindergarten classroom
that's where and I think even though
they're kind of trolling Trump I think
Trump like you said would probably have
that same feeling like obviously gay
people exist but I just don't want you
grooming my children yeah right I also
think just both the Trump and DeSantis
teams on social media especially on
Twitter are really cringe it's just
getting too much yeah the internet
dude I just just just stop I look if
this really worked for Gen Z I stand
corrected if if the kids on Tick Tock
are watching this video and now they're
inspired to vote for DeSantis they're
not going all right
I think it's good I don't think it was
made by them either they're reposting
proud elephant I'm just like
it's it's getting I don't know man it's
cringe it's it's cringe on both sides
yeah but I think it's something to
Santa's influencer what's what's gonna
happen though is the Trump influencers
and the DeSantis influencers are just
going to kill themselves and we're gonna
have the same outcome of 2020 probably
they're gonna they're gonna nuke each
other in the primary then refuse to vote
for each other that's what we need is
the Trump DeSantis get along I mean of
course grab arms and they're like
together they should just fight in the
Coliseum oh that would be winner gets
the nomination I I I uh won't vote for
DeSantis on if if he apologizes has his
team apologize and take down that deep
fake video then he's back on my list but
it's like at this point we're over a
month out I don't know if it's there's
he probably didn't even approve that it
doesn't matter yeah I guess how hard
would it be for him to be like take it
down yeah I didn't approve of that take
it down that was wrong sorry about that
guys that's all five seconds if he put
out a video and you and if they just
delete here's the thing if they delete
the tweet and then put up a tweet saying
we deleted that video because it had
deep fakes Ron is unhappy that it that
it was put up without his approval it is
no longer you know then I would be like
okay cool is your issue with the
dishonesty of the deep fake
so for almost a decade the media has
been lying about every single thing
Trump has ever done and it's more than
lying it's one it's one thing when you
have these political videos that are
like did you know that you know John
Smith voted for the for the uh hating
puppies act or like you know Alex Stein
voted against the we love puppies Bill
why doesn't he love puppies it's like oh
that Bill had nothing to do with puppies
like we get it it's manipulation
that's annoying it's bad and everybody
hates it
with trump it was even worse they were
editing videos out of context lying
about his quotes and I spend almost the
better like the better part of a decade
constantly talking to everybody saying
that's not true that never happened and
it is annoying and I hate having to do
it all the time and then Rhonda Sanders
comes out with a video his team did
where they they made deep fake images of
trump hugging and kissing fauci and so
now it's just like all of that stuff I'm
angry about they just decided to one-up
it so I'm pissed yeah a bad president
too right like we're gonna have a
republican candidate attack another
Republican candidate by fabricating
something like yeah that would never
work for journalism why are we allowing
it to stand for social media because
otherwise we just open the door for it I
would be a hypocrite if I said ah it's
no big deal because I've been
complaining about the media lying about
Trump non-stop the entire time and don't
get me wrong people are like yeah but
Trump lies about DeSantis and I'm like
and he should not but he did not create
fake images to smear Rhonda he kind of
did and again I have a problem I have a
preference for Trump again what did
Trump what did Trump create he didn't no
he didn't do an AI but they were posting
photos of the empty DeSantis Booth
saying nobody came by all day but that
wasn't the case and they ended up
getting Community noted on it it's it's
all dishonest and I think on both and
it's bad and I hate all of it yeah and
the Trump Camp shouldn't be posting
misleading things but it is
substantially worse to have someone go
onto a computer and create several
different iterations of fake images to
trick people into thinking a thing
happened that didn't happen well to be
fair and I'm not trying to be a
contrarian or White Knight for DeSantis
I love
Donald Trump
but Donald Trump was
besties with fauci in a way I mean I
know those are artists I agree with the
point I know I mean they were kind of
made even though they used a fake
artificial photo they were making a true
point so it's kind of I know hey I'm
just saying that to be contrarian if
they didn't do that the video is fine
yeah but instead
they do it I say hey that's not cool you
should take that down and then they
attack me for it and I'm just like okay
these people are disingenuous like how
about you prove that you're better than
all of the BS we've been dealing with is
Trump posting out of context Clips or
whatever like every other position
always does and we all despise it okay
that's really bad I'm annoyed by it he's
as bad as all the rest of them did
DeSantis just do worse than all of them
great all the politicians are at
Baseline lying pieces of trash and
DeSantis is one degree below them that's
where I'm at so you know all you gotta
do is tweet and be like we shouldn't
have done that and I'll say okay okay
guys because I gotta look this video
they're right Ron DeSantis has it has
really done a lot as it pertains to the
culture war and in protecting kids and
and putting up barriers to protect the
cultural values and the moral values
that we do have and that's a winning
position that's fantastic it's better
than Trump he's got a lot to go after
Trump on in terms of the primary
but they're certainly not doing
themselves any favor with this current
press team they seem to be just digging
a hole for him no and he's a young man I
don't know why he's making this push now
I think he I guess maybe sees blood in
the water maybe like a shark right now I
think he sees Trump as vulnerable you
see Candace Owens tweeted that as he's
done who DeSantis said that he's done
let me let me let me pull that tweet up
yeah but I don't think they're gonna
stop trying to investigate Trump I mean
I don't think they're not I mean it's
never going to stop they're gonna find
something I mean it's just it's gonna a
never-ending Cavalcade of charges to try
to stop him from running and I think
it's going to win I think that there
will be a time and I know Trump says
he'll fight till the end or whatever but
I think there'll be a time where they'll
say hey and I mean this is just pure
speculation where maybe he does get in
trouble for a crime and I think they're
kind of laying the groundwork for Biden
to get in trouble for a similar crime
and then maybe they both get pardoned so
Candace Owens tweeted sorry to say sorry
to the saying uh sorry to the say it but
the DeSantis campaign was Dead on
Arrival and it's time to admit it tons
of mistakes needed to be more upfront
about his intention to run doesn't come
across as honest and he's boring you can
say it shouldn't matter but it does he
also needed someone more like Kaylee
mcinany rather than Patty Christina
Pasha running comms the influencers that
are still cheerleading for him are those
that recently moved to his State and
want to reap the benefits for standing
firm beside beside him through his
inevitable loss I'm not knocking The
influencer Hustle just calling it as I
see it they know he can't win either
also their weird takeover of their
Community notes gives people a fact
Checker Vibe sometimes the notes they
add don't actually debunk anything
getting very snopes-like Jenna Alice
says Candace probably consulted
president Jeb for this spot on take
Candice says when you authored this
tweet did you think it was funny clever
interesting generally interested in your
thought process on this honestly chat
GPT could have come up something better
um highlighting that one just because
like
is this IT consulting with Jeb to
criticize that Santa's campaign his
poles are tanking he's he's just on the
fighting like I just I I don't
understand why this is the conversation
we're having I think it's a legitimate
conversation to have should we allow or
permit faked images to be used in any
sort of campaign setting I think that's
a good question for journalism for
integrity but generally like I am tired
of Republicans fight each other like
just come up with something interesting
to say about policy that's actually all
I need right now I don't care if your
staffs hate each other I don't care
about any of that because what I want is
someone the person who is leading policy
conversation for me right now is RFK Jr
and he's a Democrat so what are the
Republicans doing yeah I would have
gotten more stances sure but he's a
Democrat he's not going to happen Alex
and I both had to preface we're like I
swear we love Trump yeah but yeah you
know because it's terrifying they become
very culty especially on the influencer
sign and online it's they're a little
they're a little rabid I have no worries
about Trump supporters the DeSantis
people are ravenous I think they both
are I've gotten it from both sides
because I get accused of being paid by
both of them I think they're both pretty
pretty violent certainly Trump has his
his pit bulls that are you know yelling
but like
when I when when like I don't describe
it we've been doing this for a long time
I've been critical of trump on a lot of
things people got really mad at me when
I said that he lost in 2020 and they
were like you're crazy and then sure
enough Trump was never inaugurated like
they're like in March it'll come but it
is nowhere near as bad like having
having people be like yeah Tim's an
idiot but it's okay because I say these
things versus the Santa's people like yo
I put out a tweet about Trump doing
something wrong and I'll get Trump
supporters being like yeah I hear you I
put a tune about DeSantis and I get a
hundred tweets instantly of people
insulting me and I'm just like yo yo
dude all you're doing is making it worse
for Descendants maybe that's their
intention well this is they're just
trying to hurt him this is why I don't
think the fighting will ever stop
because I mean politics is just
Hollywood for ugly people so they're
going to continue to create a way to
fight with each other to get more clout
or get more clicks I mean that's why
they always put in these fake bills that
are never going to get past so I think
that's like to be honest DeSantis
probably loves this now this fighting I
mean I I'm just once again speculating
that because now we just talk about him
now we're on to Santa's on the same
level as Trump so kind of helps to start
but he's not that's the point where
Megan is he's his polls have been cut in
half well yeah I know but I'm just
saying he has the cachet that he's a
threat to Trump trump does seem a little
threatened here's what I think
I think Ron could be the front runner
right now if he had a good press team
despite the fact that he was hemming and
hung about whether he was going to run
his his policy says enough like what
he's done in Florida like he is probably
the best politician in terms of
leadership that we have in this country
and that his press team comes out and
just keeps setting fires over and over
again and I I for whatever reason they
they aren't fixing it and they think
it's good I don't get it I would agree
with that well Veep that show Veep on
HBO that's like a documentary like
really I'm telling you the people that
are working these staffs even the high
people uh that I meet with you know that
run marjories or any politician these
people aren't that exceptional Tim
they're all just like normal people I
mean I'm not I'm just being honest so
they're just trying to figure it out
this is probably Christina's first
presidential campaign so they don't have
any idea what the hell they're doing I
mean I I don't think someone like my I
don't think Michael malice would take a
job doing something like that with them
he would with the libertarian party or
whatever but they need a Michael Manley
yeah that Michael would be good for them
yeah like I don't think he would work
with the santis maybe if the price is
right whatever I don't you know Michael
being anarch has he might ideologically
say I'm not interested but uh for the
libertarian party that was the thing
that he was going to be the press
secretary someone like Michael malice is
so culturally historically and press
savvy
if the Santa's campaign were to hire
someone of his caliber right when they
started he'd be the front runner no
question yes and he's snarky he's good I
mean a mouse would be a great mouthpiece
and he's a good person right he's a
really good person apparently a great
actor too he just did an episode of
normal world with uh oh yeah I saw that
clip yes everybody check it out actually
do not check out normal world go to
Prime Time with Alexander right now do
not
some cast do not mention get your super
chats in get your super chats
um Tim have you would you consider ever
getting into politics at this stage no
because I kind of admit any idea how
much power I would have to give up
hold on that's a Lex Luthor quote well
it's kind of I'm the same way we go down
to Congress we do these shows and I'm
like I can feel the invite like that
they would be happy to have newscasters
come and support the campaigns but like
I don't want I don't want it I don't
want that I don't want to go take the
the title I don't need the title to
change it it's also very disheartening
getting involved in politics on the
campaign level
um because you realize that a lot of
these people are just kind of
circle jerking each other and that's why
nothing gets done
and by that you mean it's a circle of
jerks who are patting each other on the
back changing directional momentum yes
it's just a bunch of guys all patting
each other you mean it's like like a
fraternity because it kind of felt like
college when I was at Congress like a
bunch of yeah isn't it funny yeah it's
like it's seriously when you're walking
through the halls of Congress it's like
college Adore Me yeah no really it's
like you walk through Longfellow Hall in
those Halls it's very weird though
because I actually did an official tour
and I don't know if I said this last
time but as soon as you go on the
official Capital Tour they bring you in
for like this 20 minute video that gives
you the history and like within the
first minute it's like these are
hollowed grounds oh that was built on
the backs of slaves like literally
immediately they make you feel so guilty
but then after I watch that video then
I'm walking around everywhere and in DC
for the rest of my trip I'm like oh my
gosh this is built by slave this is
built by slave it is it has this kind of
creepy old College weird video the funny
thing about was it like uh uh what
building were you mentioning long long
fellows yeah I think it's there's like a
little Market where you go in and you
can grab stuff and then like scan a card
or whatever to pay for it there's like a
Subway in a Baskin Robbins
yo it like walking around and then it's
like the the rival team is it like
across the hall and they're like that's
where AOC is and I'm just like this is
so childish well the George Santos I
remember going there and there was
literally people camping out CNN when he
first got in there camping out in those
hallways and just The Vibes in there
it's just very weird I love him
something like I didn't say I was Jewish
I said I was Jewish well I'm kind of
Jewish I kind of vibe with that too but
uh no you know there's this weird thing
now where the conservative movement is
The Counter Culture so George Santos
being like an openly gay man that is
like you know he's worn drag but he's
like did he really though he denied it
didn't he well who cares who cares I've
worn a dress whatever but my my point is
uh it's like he's The Counter Culture
because he's like the gay guy that's not
for the gay agenda so that's like I
think I think that's why successful or
fits in because he's like yeah well I
did a review of uh uh the White House
corresponds in her Fashion on Twitter
yeah
fresh like
like something that conservatives
sometimes need because they have this
reputation for being too buttoned up his
tweets are great too but if you're gonna
slam George Santos for being a liar why
don't you get the rest of them yeah they
all lie yeah I want to jump to the story
here because we'll talk about cultural
stuff this one is it's it's terrifying
and funny at the same time the
post-millennial PornHub pulls out of
Virginia over age verification law what
wait wait what
are you hold on there a minute they've
blocked users in Virginia from accessing
the site in reaction to the State's new
age verification law according to 8 News
the new law takes effects July 1st would
require porn websites to verify using
the state are at least 18 before they
can access adult content
so instead of you know verifying age
they were just like then you look at any
porn they did the same thing in Utah in
early may they they are so desperate to
show children adult images they boycott
the state when they can't well I don't
think that's it I just because they
don't want to deal with any of the legal
ramifications when having to certify all
these people because then now they're
liable if they show kids porn so I just
think that's why they do it because the
law is even right so what you're saying
is Pornhub has no problem operating in
the states if it means children can
access their content well yeah I mean
they want kids to access it but they
don't want to have the risk the Legacy
it's too much work for PornHub to have
to make sure kids aren't using this
that's fair yeah I agree with you I'd
say yes it's too much it's not cost uh
beneficial for them in May when they
blocked Utah because Utah made the same
you have to be able to show your
driver's license or verify they're like
this is crazy having to show your ID
every time you come to Pornhub it's just
not going to protect children like that
was their actual complaint they said
that this is a ridiculous way to handle
it so like strip clubs that don't check
IDs yeah but Tim we're joking about this
but the United Nations came out and
saying they want to get rid of age of
consent laws so it's like they really do
want to show kids adult content and then
when we talk about PornHub like you know
they say it's so crazy for a kid under
18 to look at porn which I agree with
but like a 14 year old can get a
mastectomy I mean you know it's just
it's so weird yeah yeah 18 year old you
know 17 year old can't get a tattoo but
they can get gender reassignments
they're chanting that they're coming for
our children yes and then when people
are like hey did you hear what they said
they're like no no they didn't say it
they didn't say it but you know they do
say it all the time we say it every year
yeah it's our it's our chant we always
say it was just a joke
no we we say it all the time but this
one time we actually didn't say we just
say it all the time another weird
twisting the PornHub thing is that
Louisiana also has an age verification
lot but PornHub never blocked them and
did comply did they yeah and I don't
know why that is they just said okay
Louisiana it's because they're so
backwards they wouldn't be able to
prosecute it or something losing I went
to LSU is the wildest place if you guys
spend any time in Louisiana because it
was the last state to change its
drinking age laws from 18 to 21 they
were like the LA the last day to get
Federal funding for the roads so the
roads and highways suck in New Orleans
yeah that's see that's Louisiana it's
like this thing it's called lagnappy
it's like a little extra like they have
this very nice kind of party atmosphere
but because of that the city's like run
like trash you know the whole State's
just not run very well it's crazy I mean
we we talked about this uh this past
week there are tons of things you can't
do in public that you can do online in
public which makes no sense there are
tons of things we wouldn't allow someone
to do at a brick and mortar
establishment we allow them to do online
which makes no sense I think it's
because you can't walk into an adult
bookstore you get your ID checked you
can't walk into a section you get your
ID checked online you can no ID check
that's insane to me it should be that
every porn website or adult website
requires registration and verification
before you can use it sorry that's just
that's just the way it works well
there's an interesting discussion going
on about Twitter in that regard too
because you can create a Twitter account
at 13 but they they also allow porn they
should yeah hold on hold on I think
Twitter
Tech so here's the technicality
it's not so much Twitter's business
if you go out into Times Square with a
big photograph of porn
you'll get arrested
so if you post porn on Twitter where
children can see it it's legal it's it
should be the same crime
I don't understand the argument for yes
I understand you can't play videos of
porn out in the public but I should be
able to play it in the public on Twitter
where children can see no no no none of
that none of that what do you think the
remedy for that is police enforcing the
law well how would they enforce that
they would see an account post the
illegal content then subpoena the
company and say under this law it's
illegal and a judge orders you to hand
over the data of the individual then
they would go get a warrant like they
would go to the house and investigate
and like any other criminal case like
let me ask you a question a guy wearing
a ski mask is is handing out porn mags
to people in Times Square and holding a
big how do they stop that
shoplifting is rampant in San Francisco
because we're letting it be just because
we never enforce the law doesn't mean we
just don't do it anymore we have to be
like yo we got to stop it we need more
resources for cyber crimes though I was
gonna say do you think
do you think cybercrime research
you send a police officer in person like
do we have a gap in law enforcement
where they are not trained to uh
it's not it's not that because many of
these people post their their own videos
to the public under their own names it's
that law enforcement and government
can't keep up with technology yeah so
like they don't have a big enough
presence on Twitter to catch them no
it's that if you go to a cop and say uh
if you go to a police officer police
station right now and say there's a guy
who lives a block away from here who is
posting he was showing pornographic
images in public and children could see
it that cop's gonna go whoa okay let's
write this on where was it it was on
Twitter he'll go oh I don't care about
that yeah yeah what's the difference
well and I I think I told you this
before Tim but they I had a serious
stalker who was stalking me through
Twitter YouTube
no he was not he he wasn't funny
um but it was a pretty serious soccer
and the FBI ended up getting involved
and I had an agent from the Cyber crimes
unit who called me and he said have you
tried calling Twitter and YouTube and I
said with all due respect sir if you
think I could call Twitter or YouTube
you should not be working in cyber
crimes and this was a federal agent FBI
agent you can't take a big poster of two
adults having sex and put it in your
front window for everyone in the world
to walk past and say you can't do that
yeah but Tim if you want to Legalize It
by all means go to legislature and have
them all vote to make that legal yeah
but my buddy Cassidy Campbell another
guy Alex Rosen they do these Predator
approaching videos Tim and I'm sure
you've seen those where they'll go in
some cities the cops do get involved but
they'll show Cops a whole cachet of
these are texts messages this guy thinks
he's messaging a 13 year old kid in the
cops they have the evidence they'll say
oh we can't touch it so it's it I think
it comes down yeah back to blue baby
yeah I know it comes down to you know
are they actually they'll give you a
ticket for having a busted headlight
that you didn't know about they'll they
they'll they'll you're a day past your
plate registration you'll get a ticket
you'll be speeding you'll be under the
limit but they'll pull you over and give
you a speeding ticket anyway these
stories are rampant everybody has some
ridiculous story I knew a dude who uh
turned right at a right red light and
they mailed him a a blowing a red light
ticket yeah because he didn't stop long
enough no he did oh they said the the it
thought he ran the light outright yeah
they don't care when it comes to petty
crime they'll enforce it with a hammer
when it comes to covert restrictions
they will lock you up hair salon owner
right to jail you own a cafe in
Minnesota and you open up for a couple
days they hunted her down in Iowa to
make sure and this is the shift to make
sure she suffered attila's gym you want
to open your gym so people can exercise
because you disagree with the edict
issued by the governor the cops will
show up with smiles on their faces and
arrest you but heaven forbid any one of
these cops when they're standing outside
of a club that is doing a sex show that
they've invited children to the cops in
Texas said sorry we won't do anything
about that I think it's the the
difference of putting up like porn in a
front window facing out onto the street
and putting it on Twitter is that on
Twitter it's parentally supervised like
you're what a kid can't get internet
without that's not true buying a router
and having a or buying a phone I kind of
agree with what Ian saying though
there's a difference between like
posting a picture and then sending that
posted picture directly to somebody if
that makes sense like I'm not talking
about that I'm saying if you post a
tweet of porn as many people do I view
that the exact same as taking a big sign
of the porn picture and stick it in the
ground outside
well then it's the school should be you
know an argument over resources and an
argument for Public Access
no it's not what if it costs 100 bucks
to get into something then it's not
public okay A a kid who doesn't have bus
fare is not the issue if you post it in
public you are granting access to but
like that's the issue just because some
kids can't get on Twitter doesn't mean
it's not public it is public that's the
argument it's not I don't know if it
legally you would consider internet
public it is it is it's literally it's
illegally considered public
if it's public then how come they a guy
can shut it down
there's there's shut down a public park
yes you need the government to do that
so there's that Elon can shut down
Twitter so so slow down there Ian first
there's things called privately on
public spaces where uh in New York for
instance that's what occupy what's
and Chase Plaza and Deutsche Bank
privately owned but public and so there
were certain restrictions on what they
couldn't couldn't do and so once it got
to a certain point of the protest they
couldn't shut it down Chase was smart
and shut down their Plaza instantly
before any of that could happen Twitter
is privately owned but it's already been
ruled a public space hence politicians
when they tweet they create public
forums they cannot block people courts
have already stated that now I think
this I'm suing AOC right over this
because she blocked you and it's a
public space she doesn't have a right to
do it it is in public period it's not
it's not up for debate it is the courts
have already said it so the issue is law
enforcement knows that adults are po are
publishing images in public that
children can get access to but for some
reason they don't care they won't go
anywhere near it ours our society is in
decay
go back 30 years and watch what happens
if a guy would print out a big poster
with with people having sex on it and
stand in public in in the Town Center
waving it at people he would like bad
things would happen to that guy the
agent arrested data proliferation we
haven't been able to keep up you can
make 100 million copies of something now
but we don't have 100 million copies of
the cop we only have one cop so you need
AI I think we need artificial
intelligence to police no social media
oh no I mean you give me a better option
no I'd love to hear a better one
terrible at distinguishing things right
it's better than no people like zero
people is even worse than they are the
issue is not
that we need a better system for it the
issue is quite simply the culture
police will see it and go meh it's like
how do you find out who did it even
because a lot of the accounts are fake
or so how about this you can't if you
shoot Twitter then you destroy Twitter
how about this in all instances where an
individual under their given name and
photograph publish it
then the investigation is quite minimal
you then
go knock on their door and say Mr Smith
did you publish this image to your
Twitter account you did place behind
your hands behind your back you're under
arrest for posting lewd images in public
did you know that in many states if you
have a gun
and that gun is in a position where a
child could get access to it that is a
felony yeah so like if it's in your room
locked in the closet oh hold on there a
minute it's got to be in a safe
they have these child protection laws
what about West Virginia we already
talked about it open lewdness is illegal
what about retweeting porn should that
those people also be arrested that's an
interesting question that we'll be up
for it is kind of a gray area well
that's a that requires precedent and
that's a normal process in the United
States law a police officer will say you
published this image to your you know 10
000 followers they'll say no I retweeted
something that was already public then
the argument becomes a guy was handing
out pictures of porn in public handed
you one and you held it up in the air
for everyone you are now in trouble with
like um when when data is leaked like
government leaks and things and then
people retweet the data like are they
committing the same felony that the
person that's a whistleblower because
they're basically holding up the elite
no because it's not illegal to share it
it's illegal to steal it so when it
comes to like the Pentagon papers the
question is was it illegally obtained
well there's whistlebar protections the
news media committed no crime by
publishing that information
Tim I want to make a point about the
culture though and it's like this is a
more simple analogy not just the fact
that everybody's trying to basically
give kids gender reassignment surgery
and make everybody get an abortion but
just look at the the change of our
architecture from the 60s and 70s
brutalism I mean hey it's this weird
post-modern era of just crap like even
the newest baseball stadium in Texas we
had the ballpark in Arlington built in
like 99 it's just beautiful you know
grandiose epic and a ballpark the newest
one they built I forget it's called
Globe Life or forget what it's even
called and it looks like a Costco I'm
just saying in the past 20 years where
we've gone down when it comes to
architecture just imagine brutalism yeah
everything's everything's a white box
and that's crap that's that's terrible
no there's no art there's we we but you
know what it is I was talking to Sheamus
about it he was saying that before the
internet and print this was the art
medium to see the great works was the
buildings we would produce then as we
move into newspaper and radio art and
creativity moved into those spaces
building started becoming less and less
relevant in the discussion right think
that's part of it I think it's also
there's a lot of planned obsolescence
that goes into that yeah
it's like to make everyone feel like
there's no uh Regional significance
right like if you're in New York City
you can tell by the buildings and
they're supposed to be different than
the buildings that are in San Francisco
which are supposed to be different than
the buildings that you might find in
like a major city in Montana whereas now
you get major corporations that put up
the same blank building everywhere so
there's no sense of identity and
therefore you can't cultivate any sort
of uh Regional Pride and it's like when
people build new houses there's always
problems but houses built in like the
70s and 60s it just lasts a test of time
it seems like so there's something
there's like a degradation of the
Carpenters like like look at this the
the uh gargoyles and stuff outside of
these buildings in New York City they
can't even repair them we don't even
have the same people the stone masons
that can even do that Plastering it used
to be like the big thing there are very
few true Plastering Crews left on the
issue of porn let me give you guys a
very simple scenario if you want to post
it to your Twitter account your account
has to be age verif verification locked
that's it so you will make a post and if
you publish it to people now you're in
trouble if like to if open to the public
for children if you want to do adult
content to make it safe and legal you
put a a age restriction filter on it and
then if a kid comes across it they can't
access it and the only people who can
are those who verify their accounts on
Twitter I'll give you a real world
example you walk into a 7-Eleven back
when I was a kid and there were some
magazines but those magazines were in
black plastic you could not see the
magazine you could see the top that it
would say the name Hustler Playboy but
you'd like oh man you couldn't see it
and kids weren't able to buy it I can't
sell you that so you couldn't actually
open it up it was wrapped you couldn't
see you could only see it was a product
so it was in public but not displaying
anything for kids to see what about if
someone's sitting on a park bench with a
Playboy reading it and there's a kid
like 500 100 feet away walking by yeah
typically then a cop will be like hey
buddy come on their kids around here put
that away but if the kid walks up behind
the guy and looks at the magazine over
his shoulder then typically someone will
say hey buddy put that thing away if a
kid would be the one that made the
mistake of that now you're talking about
simple like a Judicial discretion I
guess the question is is it illegal to
have a Playboy open in a public park
that the question of legality is the
interpretation of the judge he a cop
could say disorderly conduct for
anything you do you can fart in public
and a cop can be like that's disorderly
you're under arrest until 2 judge the
judge will then determine whether or not
you actually violated that statute
I know I got a felony for farting in
public it was gross it's really bad a
lot of poop in that part oh one of those
yeah it's really nice like a horizontal
I went to jail for a long time
no but uh
I don't know just got out when it comes
to the porn stuff on the internet I I
think that's kind of the the most
cancerous thing of the reason why kids
are so sexualized and I think that's why
we have a lot of this I'm depressed well
not just a depression but the sexual
confusion because you look at like a
trans person you might be attracted to
the boobs I think you see a penis
because they go to a drag queen story
time at a young age so I'm just saying
we're over sexualizing our children and
that's having just it's having an effect
that we can't you know quantify or
whatever we can't figure out what the
hell that's going to equal because we
don't have any past Generations that
we're exposed we kind of do it's it's
creating sexual dysfunction we're saying
that um uh erectile dysfunction is
skyrocketing our young men and uh
testosterone's way down that could be
Plastics I think that's probably our
diet and stuff like that but kids kids
human beings were never meant to be
exposed to this level of information
period that yeah okay but I understand
information access is just a thing that
we're going to learn to adapt with
children being able to get instant
access to porn on Twitter that's a
problem that was an oversight of the
2000s 2000 that people didn't realize
when the internet arrived that they
should be protecting kids brands from it
well Ted Bundy said they should Ted
Bundy said if you don't want your kids
to end up like me keep them away from
porn I think interesting the way Twitter
should work is the moment your account
posts porn available to the public you
get an instant age verification that's
what I'm talking about AI that you'd use
AI for something like that but it could
fail but I think you could use AI to do
that because if a person's like oops I
forgot you don't want to throw them in
prison for that necessarily I forgot
what I forgot to post 18 age
verification on that on mine and you're
like whoops I accidentally threw a
Playboy in front of a bunch of kids like
what like that's when you bring up like
wanting to read a pornographic magazine
in a park for me it's like but why do
you want it if you're going to park
where presumably our children whoever
like yeah
earlier is there there is there is a
reasonable this to enforcing the law
that is upon the discretion of the
officer it is unreasonable in my opinion
that officers do not arrest the people
who are engaging in these crimes
completely unreasonable it would be
unreasonable it is unreasonable in my
opinion so
if you get pulled over
and it's an honest mistake and you
weren't speeding that much the
reasonable thing to do is a warning and
cops do that a lot that's police
discretion and many officers do a good
job I have had some negative encounters
with police officers if most people have
where one time I was not speeding I got
a ticket cop told me to basically screw
myself and that got my license suspended
that bothers me it bothers me that that
kind of thing can exist where a cop can
screw your life up through no fault of
your own but we can't get him to arrest
people who are exposing children to
adult sex shows like that's my like I
recognize pencils of erasers bad cops
exist and these things happens I'm not
um it's under the water under the bridge
I'm like okay you know these are things
that are part of the system but why then
do we struggle to stop this because they
are focused primarily on immediate
Public Safety so like driving is a big
part of it they don't want a car to hit
a human in the human time like the kids
getting sexualized doesn't have like an
immediate
thing you notice like there's no
immediate change in their physical
health when they when it happens so the
cop doesn't really have like a thing to
stop right away I mean when you think
about it and you realize what's
happening then you can start to make the
argument that we need to do some
preventative measures but they're more
interested in just like stopping
violence I just think our culture is
shattered
I think that it's the internet has
ripped it to shreds there's no more
unified sense of morality and now among
cops for the most part they're just like
I want to keep my head down and stay out
of it
so in Texas famously you had a drag show
with kids and they were sexualized
things going on in there and the cops
were like I ain't doing anything about
this and it's just like yo we could just
Google the law and show you it's illegal
and the cops like don't look at me I'm
not getting involved that's insane yeah
because cops are just going to follow
orders from whoever is telling them the
order you know whether it's like the
chief or you know go down different
levels so these cops aren't going to go
out of their way to actually do any
vigilante justice or stand up for what's
right they're just going to literally
follow a procedure I'll tell you what
what happened check out the story from
the post millennial Michigan house makes
using wrong pronouns of felony the bill
makes it a felony for someone to make an
individual quote feel terrorized
frightened or threatened and is
punishable by up to five years in prison
and ten thousand dollar fine
they write on Tuesday Michigan State
House passed a bill making it a felony
HB 4474 is designed to replace
Michigan's ethnic intimidation act to
expand categories of protected classes
to include identity gender identity
expression and sexual orientation and it
passed 59 to 50. it is not yet law but I
guarantee you
guarantee
we will see if this passes I'm not sure
so sure that it will but maybe I mean
it's Michigan you got you know I think
whitmer's still there right you will see
people arrested for this and you know
why I I have absolute confidence in
saying that because Jordan Peterson
warned us how am I was it seven or eight
years ago and then in Canada we have
seen several instances where people have
been criminally charged for using wrong
pronouns I imagine this violates some
sort of free First Amendment issue like
you can't tell me what I can and can't
say to you
that's my right to say whatever I want
there might be you know I'm not saying
that the person's not going to throw a
punch if I if I anger them and then
they'll go to jail or whatever but
you that's like the essence of this
nation the Supreme Court ruled on three
or three creative uh this this uh
Christian web designer who said under
Colorado's anti-discrimination laws uh I
feel as though my I would be compelled
to make wedding websites for same-sex
couples if they approached me about it
and I don't think that's fair and one of
the things that came up in the decision
today was uh the justices wrote Colorado
under the interpretation of the law
Colorado currently has they would compel
this woman into speech that she doesn't
agree with and so it's kind of similar
to what you're saying I wonder if in
some way there is already legal
precedent that you know this is Michigan
so they can't necessarily take Colorado
law but if we have federal law that says
you can't compel speech like at what
point do you prioritize the First
Amendment maybe they would what they're
saying with this is that if you it's
like I'm pretty sure the bill is
specifically about in the in the act of
committing a crime if you do this thing
it's a it's a it's um what do they call
it like a hate crime thing it's a hate
crime thing but it's um it's uh I forgot
what it's called in law when they add on
to the crime because of a thing you did
I forgot I'm I'm I can't do it right now
yeah
yeah like a secondary offense I think is
what they call it like you can't get
pulled over here
yeah I mean it's bad it's a bad
precedent but I think it was Nuance bro
who's talking he's like it's it's kind
of comparable to the lynching
balanced it's like well lynchings
already illegal it's already illegal to
harass people it's already illegal to do
these things in this bill
to make someone feel terrorized that's
not up to me the way you feel is the way
you choose to feel I'm not my words are
not making you feel anything I'm making
noise and then you are interpreting that
and making yourself feel a certain way
we will see someone arrested for this
yeah me I'm probably gonna get arrested
for this I'm gonna yell you know
Governor Whitmer and call her a boy and
go to jail can't go to Michigan anymore
no they'll say that you were you were
right and all that stuff can you get
arrested for it or is it just an
additional charge that you would get or
it makes the charge more severe if
you're also misgendering them like I
think this in and of itself is a hate
crime to make someone feel terrorized
frightened or threatened by misgendering
them well in any way it literally I
don't think it specifies to make someone
feel afraid intimidate means willful
course of conduct involving repeated or
continuing harassment of another
individual that would cause a reasonable
individual to feel terrorized frightened
or threatened and that actually caused
the victim to feel terrorized frightened
or threatened intimidate does not
include constitutionally protected
activity or conduct that serves a
legitimate purpose well constitutional
protected activity is calling a man a
woman that's right
but apparently not no it is
you would think so there that will be up
for the courts but we are we are
Marching the direction so look
Jordan Peterson this was his big thing
was it bill c16 or whatever it was back
in the day he was like what's the next
thing he's like people go to jail for
this they all mocked him and they said
you're lying they were like Dr Peterson
the penalty is a fine and then he goes
and what happens if you don't pay the
fine
and everyone's like
oh
you go to jail and he's like oh so what
did I say that was wrong
and then sure enough we've seen it there
was like one guy who wouldn't call his
daughter male pronouns so they arrested
him or something like that
what is that Canada oh let me see if uh
let me see if we had a member uh one
night that was afraid to say anything
bad about Trudeau because he was a
Canadian and he's like I can't like you
guys can make the jokes but I won't make
any jokes here on your after show Danny
polish shook doesn't even make that
money it's the Trudeau jokes and he's 20
he's like 2021 father arrested for
discussing child's gender transition and
Defiance of court order
I mean you know teenager was born female
and he was uh kept referring to her with
the look at this look at the New York
Post wrote referring to his teen
daughter uh referring to him with the
pronouns she and her born female okay
New York Post
that he was found in contempt of court
and arrested Tuesday for calling his
calling the teen his daughter and
publicly referring to him with the
pronouns she and her the teenager was
born as a female
and that's in Canada yep that's already
happening here though in California they
want it to be child abuse if you don't
affirm your child exactly I'm telling
you it is it is we got it everybody got
really mad at Target for the tug
friendly bathing suit but then when you
really looked at it through marketing of
VP was giving you know 2.1 million
dollars to glsen which actually you know
is a corporation that helps kids
transition behind their parents back you
know so they really are I mean they're
not secretive out in the open they've
been taught in part with organizations
like that for like over a decade though
Target is one of the headline sponsors
for New York City's youth pride and was
one of the founding sponsors of New York
City youth Pride so it wasn't just I'm
just surprised it took this long for
people to realize but I think the
northern tentacles were reaching I think
the narrative around pride in these
organizations shifted over time like
over the last decade it went from being
like you're gonna come out to your
parents and they're not going to accept
you and you need a chosen family who
will embrace you and love you to being
like you're going to tell your parents
that you want to undergo medical
intervention surgery to alter your your
sexual characteristics and they're going
to say no and that's terrible and you're
gonna have to look for people to support
you like the conversation has
dramatically shifted as uh our our
leftist Progressive counterparts have
embraced gender ideology it's the
Bolsheviks
they took the ownership of children
imagine a court ordering you
to not refer to your own daughter as a
as your daughter
and he got arrested for it this is back
in uh
uh 2021 March I think it was
yeah and so yeah like in California
they're they're they're passing that
bill that says you have to affirm your
kids otherwise it's child abuse they'll
take your kids from you not no compelled
speech laws I don't like that I mean
affirming the kid isn't necessarily a
speech thing because if they if they
start making you compelling you to say
something then they can make you
say things about your leader and no
that's I mean this is
a specific thing the Supreme Court just
ruled on yesterday that we shouldn't be
that state laws shouldn't compel you to
do something that violates your yours
the way you would otherwise speak but
again they're dancing the line they're
they're sort of saying like well we're
not saying that you can say something
we're just saying that will punish you
if you don't say this other thing well I
think the dad was really disappointed
because if you notice in this particular
situation this was a female to male
transition giving them no advantage in
sports now if this is the other way
around where it was a male transitioning
to a female maybe she would have been a
great athlete like Leah Thomas and then
he would have been more proud of her
maybe it's only that maybe it's on the
dad that's what I'm saying I think it's
the dad's fault
the father was trying to find Medical
Solutions that didn't involve drugs and
they were they were like nope drugs
yeah wow well that's the thing Tim they
literally this has happened with the
Chloe Cole they'll tell the children's
parents that the child is going to kill
themselves if they do not get this
gender referring surgery when in
actuality desistance rights are between
like 65 and 98 so your best opportunity
the best course of action seemingly for
the child this is what Europe found is
nothing yeah non-intervention not
intervention and when they say stuff
like if you don't do this will take
their own life or harm themselves it's
actually the inverse
if if the suicidality uh ideation in
action is higher among the transgender
population but children are 60 to 90
likely to desist with no intervention
then intervention actually increases the
rate of of suicidality
yes we don't want to get medical
misinformation but ssris actually
increase your uh suicidal idolization
well I'll keep it simply make sure you
find a good doctor you trust yes we're
just people on the internet okay I'm not
a doctor do not listen to anything from
me medically yeah so I'm I'm speaking
not not as a medical doctor who can talk
about I'm speaking my opinion based on
the studies showing decisions rates are
this high but uh so what I should say is
if those studies are true logic would
dictate the best course of action is X
but uh not a doctor you are to confirm
what you're saying Alex antidepressants
and suicide risk from the National
Institute of Health uh 2005 systematic
review controlled trials compared ssris
with other active treatments or placebos
found almost two-fold increase in the
odds of fatal and non-fatal suicide acts
that's what was exposed to SSH yeah
National Institute of Health wow that's
the first thing that came up when I
typed SSRI suicide it's no joke and I'm
not a doctor at all but I'm telling you
not once during the pandemic did they
ever tell anybody to go get some
exercise eyes and eat better I mean
that's I think that's where it comes
down to a lot of our mental health
problems too is the crap that we eat and
we don't exercise and just because I'm
sure a lot of people are like what's an
SSRI it's a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor
there you go now you know what SRI
stands for the more you know
depression yeah take Inhibitors well
you've been working out a lot how do you
feel I feel better knowing I I think
that's like uh you know for me I've had
a challenging stuff I lost my mom not
that long ago and I remember exercising
and stuff because I was very depressed
about that that's the only thing that
made me feel better
um so I think if it helped me with that
it would help everybody else and I know
it's not a placebo it's not just going
to fix problems with people that
exercise that are depressed but I'm just
saying there are natural remedies I
believe instead of just taking a magic
pill I've been doing a mile on the on
the bike on the assault bike and it's
like it lowers my blood pressure like I
was just working my lower body a little
bit of the upper body but afterwards for
like six hours I just have lower blood
pressure it's fantastic for my mind I
don't think a human body is designed for
a sedentary lifestyle yeah and that's
unfortunately you know one of the the
nice things about having you know
non-manual labor jobs is that you could
get to be in the air conditioning and
you know whatever else on the other hand
now you are putting your body at a
permanent state of rest which is not
good for it so unless you actively try
to find ways to be active you are more
likely to
harm your body essentially I think
that's why a lot of people are just more
mentally in general because our entire
society and lifestyle is antithetical to
The Human Condition both mentally and
physically yeah well you mentioned birth
control and that's one of the things
that I find super interesting because
you probably tell us too there's this
study that says uh if you start birth
control before the age of 20 you're uh
130 percent more likely to develop
depression
in commit suicide and all women uh this
is like a one of the largest studies
ever done on this was 260 000 women is
published by Cambridge press University
press
they found that women any of any age are
90 more likely to develop symptoms of
depression if they take birth control
and to me one of the interesting things
about this and maybe you can talk about
the two but uh my anecdotal experiences
all no girls who it's not to sleep
around I know that's the thing
conservative men always bring up and
it's not an unreasonable thing to
question about Society but they're told
oh you have bad really painful cramps
it's disruptive to your your education
to your job get a birth control your
skin anything they'll use it as this
treat all pill but really those are
symptoms that your hormones are out of
whack so instead of treating the hormone
imbalance through diet through food
through exercise they just say cover
that and progress prolong the problem
and then we don't talk about the
consequences 2020 was the 60th
anniversary of when the FDA signed off
on birth control as a form of
contraceptive or the pill and yet we're
still just now acknowledging that women
become extremely depressed because of it
like that seems crazy to me you put your
body's hormones on pause for years on
end and expect there to be no
consequences no and that's the issue is
that there's not informed consent for
women for so many things that are given
to them especially birth control these
young girls I was put on it at 14 for
acne for something minuscule and I
wasn't told hey you might get really
depressed hey you might become suicidal
and none of these women are told this
they are expected to read it's like the
terms of service and nobody reads what's
in the damn box and so they but female
unhappiness nobody's talking about this
relative they're subjective well-being
our subjective well-being as women has
fallen both absolutely and relatively to
that of men despite there being so much
progress and there's actually a really
funny Yale study that talks about this
the Paradox of declining female
happiness of female unhappiness because
they talk about they're like wow we're
making so much progress but women are
more unhappy than ever because we're
because we're severing women from their
biological nature from femininity and
pumping them full of hormones and
telling them the only way you're happy
is if you're like a man and you don't
have children you get depressed they're
like and have some ssris which we now
agree then they're on a pharmaceutical
cocktail oh the birth control they don't
even ask you if I'm on birth control and
I go to my doctor and I say I'm
depressed they do not even ask you most
of the time or or mention that it might
be the birth control they just pop you
on an SSRI or they pop you on something
else and now you're on a pharmaceutical
cocktail and it gets even worse well I
look at a doctor a lot like a mechanic
basically where they don't actually want
to fix a problem they just want to cut
off the check engine light so you can't
see what the problem is and that's
basically why they just medicate you
instead of actually trying to fix the
problem fix the engine you know actually
do the hard work I just want to give you
this you know Placebo curl yeah but are
you talking about bad doctors yeah but
most doctors are because they'll just
give you an SSRI you just walk in and
say oh I'm depressed you know they don't
even ask you 10 questions about why
you're depression maybe you're going to
bed doctors yeah but this is like no no
this is the problem with doctors though
Tim is it you know this they go to
college they come out with huge debts
any doctor that spoke out against this
pandemic protocol you know got fired so
they are they are emboldened to listen
to whatever they're sure
there's no there's no House MD there's
no doctor it's like you know what I'm
going to try this unorthodox approach
because if they did if they try to
prescribe Ivermectin
no there's people so when during during
covid famously Joe Rogan found a doctor
who gave him a question he wanted
there's an exception to that rule
sometimes my point and that's the he
probably paid cash sure my point is this
most people I just this argument is like
man I hired a plumber and he broke my
toilet and I'm like so find a better
plumber like if if most plumbers you
find are bad you just gotta get it
because it'll tell you because good
doctors are inaccessible for most people
because if they accept Insurance what
happens is they turn into patient males
where they're just getting in and out
have you ever see the plumber is not a
good thing because you're not arguing my
point though the plumber analogy is not
good because basically the same company
that that sells the plumber the pipes is
telling the plumber to keep messing up
the house so they can sell the plumber
more so fine like I I don't understand
this argument where it's like my life
should be easy and I shouldn't have to
do any work to find people the majority
of doctors have to have one train of
thought so so it's their whole
livelihoods on it they'll get fired they
can't even speak out against it so you
say oh fine there's one good doctor
there's only one Peter it's not one good
doctor but there's not that many I'm
telling you how did we find like doctor
like okay look my point 99 of doctors
are going to say the covered vaccine is
great I don't even think it's just that
my point is
and
I don't know about 99 but the overall
majority
it's just it's not an answer to say
because most people in this field are
bad we're screwed it's just it's your
responsibility to make sure the people
you are working with are doing right by
you it is not my or anyone else's
response if you go to a bad insert any
trade that is your fault I think that's
multifaceted though because most people
don't know that their doctor may not be
giving them the best advice and I don't
think it's I think a lot of doctors are
becoming dishonest and they're doing
brand deals but I also think because
they're they're focusing on volume and
getting people in and out I think a
doctor should be sitting with you for an
hour or two really diving into but they
don't do that this I I just I feel like
it's not really arguing what I'm saying
so many people said I went to my doctor
and they gave me bad information I
checked online then found a different
doctor
but most people don't know what what is
it what is your argument do you know
research no no no no no do research but
can you install a transmission in your
car my brother can I'm saying can you
install a transmission in your car no
but I show you my brother I know but I'm
saying so you came to an expert so what
if every mechanic you went to was lying
to Tim so here's what I do I go online I
look up basic transmission stuff and and
you're going to learn how to install a
transmission if what let me ask you a
question when you go to a car dealer do
you take his word for it a lot of times
yeah that's a that's a mistake well this
is how it works because I actually have
my ideas how it works is in Texas if you
buy a car through a license dealer you
have to give them basically like a post
sale inspection you have to give them
make sure that it passes inspection and
if not you have to tell them it's as is
so in that sense it is good because
listen I don't like the government
getting involved in business but at
least when I sold a person car they knew
is either as is with no warranty or the
car is perfectly fine if the argument is
Big Pharma is corrupt and many doctors
just accept whatever they say and big
Pharma sponsors there's no question but
I do not accept the
the argument that a person it's it's not
a person's fault for not taking the
responsibility to do research on who
they're hiring to treat their bodies
yeah but I wouldn't know how to treat
cancer I wouldn't know how to I mean
there's a lot but let me tell you if you
went to a doctor and they prescribed
like splashing bleach in your face you'd
be like hey wait wait a minute wait a
minute there's a lot of doctors who say
oh here get this chemo and then you're
not you're not arguing like you're not
arguing what I'm saying I don't
understand well I guess what happened
I'm saying I don't trust the doctor you
say oh you can just find these great
unicorn doctors I don't think that I
think the whole entire industry has been
in fact that's that's true though RFK
Junior was saying it's yeah there are
tons of people who got prescribed a
bunch of different treatments during
covid there there are there are like
people posting on Twitter how their
doctor is doing these treatments yes but
there were there was a coalition of
doctors doing that but even that
Coalition couldn't the government could
still stop CVS from uh prescribing
Ivermectin so it doesn't even matter
even if the doctor has his best
intentions oh well I do have this
medication I'm gonna prescribe it then
you go to your CVS oh I'm sorry we're
not going to fill out your prescription
Mr pool because we this isn't authorized
for that so then so even the doctors
could be overseeded superseded no one is
arguing that there's no corruption yeah
the argument is you can't come to me and
be like I hired a plumber and he broke
my toilet it's their fault I'll be like
dude why didn't you do any research
before like it like I don't I don't know
what the argument is that the doctors
take an oath to make sure that they have
their patients best interests and I
don't think doctors follow that other
thing I I think I'm feeling it from an
individualist and you're using it from a
collectivist person it's more fair to
think of it as a fireman than a plumber
because the firemen it's life and death
they come they have to put the fire out
the right way if they go in there and
they create some sort of arson or do
something faulty You're Gonna Know
immediately and it's the same way with
doctors I mean plumbers obviously just
not life and death
um
how about this look at your cat Mr bocus
oh they want to euthanize it they just
want to doctors in Canada right now are
literally prescribing people medically
assisted suicide because they can't
afford the chair lifting we also found a
guy who said Give us 10 grand we'll give
them we'll give them stem cells and the
stem cells didn't work did he which
they're working I don't know
it's not working I mean so who who do we
so so yes and so who do we trust the guy
who said pay me a lot of money and I'll
save your cat oops it didn't work maybe
he had the best intentions and he was
correct it just didn't work or the
doctor says this treatment's not going
to work I recommend you not do it who
turned out to be correct it's just no I
don't trust a doctor that says kill your
cat and then if you say no he says okay
then give it this medicine until it dies
I'm like no off dude I'm gonna heal
my cat thank you okay I don't disagree
but my point is
we we pay for the expensive treatment
that didn't work I think it worked it's
just it's not a super hero treatment is
it supposed to work or prolong his life
yeah just like regeneration no stem
cells was supposed to work but it's it's
um experimental the drugs are supposed
to prolonged and Tim did you know the
the third leading cause of death is you
know doctor malpractice is it I don't
know if that's Google it Google it uh
cause of death yeah I think it's a third
leading cause of death behind like
whatever heart disease and cancer
um who would admit that that's like a
funny statistic well look it up look
medical medical error is the third
leading cause of death according to ihi
yeah so so this is the problem and this
is what no but let me let me just say
this Tim and I'm not trying to get
emotional because once again I have to
bring up my mother dying it was the
worst thing in my life but we told the
doctors not to give a room desvar they
still gave her room does a beer because
they could still bill her insurance
without her Authority as soon as we
signed a DNR they were able to do
whatever they want they could care less
they know Rim deserveer they know for a
fact I know I know we can't say
something no no no my point is you're
telling me that you are like I told the
doctor to do something a doctor could
still do it do you understand that the
doctor has full control they can just
mess up on your heart surgery so sure
what I'm saying is so these so it's like
so here's my point you're going this
doctor is clearly wrong would you do
heart surgery around me
no I wouldn't get that if if you go to a
doctor and the doctor says something and
you're like that doctor's wrong I should
do I should have him do my heart surgery
that makes no sense no but I'm just
saying all doctors are basically corrupt
do you think that like there's no Trump
supporting doctors but I think that
they're in the I think that's them
they're in the major minorities they're
centralized okay so much Chef gets your
medical misinformation there's a lot of
stuff I'd like to be talking I would
sound like RFK but I think if you just
look at RFK and you look at uh
correlation and causation and you can
look at a lot of stuff Tim you could see
some numbers he's he's also I think he's
wrong about a lot of stuff oh well and
I'm in favor I think about childhood
vaccines I mean we can like I said
medical misinformation you're going to
say so much but I do think it's weird
some of the schedules of vaccines for
young children uh at that young of age
and then you look at the occurrence of
autism at a rate that we've never seen
I'm not saying that
they're totally connected but I mean
it's hard to not
you know so so ourselves investigate
that's I mean yeah raise the yellow flag
and let's take a look at all this stuff
man one of the biggest issues when it
comes to any of this stuff is
if there are 50 variables in a problem
and you're aware of two of them you
might think those two things are
correlated but you don't know the other
variables so uh the trans kids for
instance is a good argument
conservatives often talk about social
contagion and then I immediately say
endocrine disruptors like there are
other things that are disrupting the
hormones of of children
that could be causing this speaking of
are we but it's like cancer clusters
they can usually figure out what's
causing something if there's a cluster
of people getting sick from the same
thing you can and especially with AI you
can put that data in and very quickly so
we should be able to figure this out but
so the answer is not that we know for
sure but that we should take all the
data available not it's it's I think we
should eight mice right we should take
we should have any kid diagnosed with
autism and we should talk about where
they live environmental factors uh
density of like uraniums or selenium or
whatever maybe in their water
medications vaccines not just any one
but all load that into an AI and it'll
show us the patterns and then we can
assess that and move forward my main
point with doctors is I do not disagree
that most doctors just say this is what
we're told to give you my point is that
is the reason why it is incumbent upon
you to go to a doctor ask questions and
then shop around well do you think most
doctors would listen to Peter Hotes
the answer is yes but to what degree
because if you go to rural areas and
Maga country you'll find most doctors
there probably would not but most could
be 51 I actually think you'll find a lot
of doctors who you're gonna have a
higher density of doctors in in major
Urban liberal centers and as Democrats
believe what CNN tells them and just
March in lockstep but I guarantee you if
you go to a trump supporting doctor he's
going to agree with you yeah a trump
supporting one yeah and there's many of
them there's a lot of them so we can put
it this simply if you are distrustful of
the medical system find a doctor who
politically aligns with you and then do
your research politics is enough though
because I think there's Trump supporting
doctors who still will pursue
to make money girls they're still going
to give out SRI you still have
responsibility it is not the
responsibility of everyone else like
evidence you come to me Tim you say I
have cancer I need help and I'm a doctor
you're going to take whatever they give
you because you're going to trust them
no when you have doctors are going to
lose their medical license if they don't
if you're if your argument is people
don't have agency money do your own
research but I'm just saying there's
questions
diet when you had pancreatic cancer and
then died I don't think that that helped
him but I'm saying I agree do you look
too you should have listened to his
doctors
experts for answers that you don't have
so yes you can do your own research but
you're still going to go with the
expert's opinion more often than not and
if you find out if so if if anyone of
any job comes to you and says the sky's
green and you go I'll take your word for
it that's on you sometimes this guy is
green you when it's a storm coming
especially it's really cool my point is
you cannot just say they're the experts
so everyone just does what they say
that's a problem but here's one should
not here's an example that's my my point
is that most people don't know that you
shouldn't take a doctor's word as the
Bible there's nothing that you can do
about this issue there's so you as
individuals
should not like we should be telling
people and this is my position
shop around for a doctor you trust that
is the answer I believe it is
counterproductive to be like no no what
if it's emergency you just go in the
emergency room you don't get to pick
your doctor yeah
like the world is not fair the world is
not perfect there was not safe if if you
are in New York City that if you have an
emergency you're going to go to a doctor
no one is arguing against that but you
said all doctors are bad not all but I'd
say the majority of them are and the
majority could be what 51 4.99 I think
that they're they're given bad
information because they're not that's
why I think it is I think they're
actually probably good inherently like
morally they're probably good but
they're going off bad information yes we
need the average person to take
responsibility for their health and not
just go oh that means instead of saying
all doctors are bad it's pointless we
say no you just have to work hard and if
you don't you don't deserve it if you
blindly trust someone to inject you in a
7-Eleven parking lot you deserve
whatever happens but it's if you do
research and to the best of your ability
to decide what is right for you because
the responsibilities incumbent upon you
then sure malpractice I believe kicks in
what if you can't afford that doctor
yeah I would exactly if you can't afford
medical treatment welcome to real life
if you can't afford a spear and you're
in the woods and a bear attacks you
that's not my problem that should be a
contrarian even though I am conservative
I actually do believe that our medical
industrial complex is totally crooked
that we need to have Caps or we should
have some sort of socialized Healthcare
I know that sounds crazy and that's not
a conservative viewpoint but I think the
basic necessity of having insulin the
fact that insulin is 200 in Texas but
it's two dollars in Mexico that's
because of corruption so agreed so we
have such a corrupt system I think it is
corrupt and that means fix it that means
you have to personally do the work to
find a good doctor but I can't change
the price of insulin you can go to
Mexico and go to Canada
Donald Trump needs to be reformed I just
hold on this is this is the main issue
right now you cannot be like no all
doctors are bad end of story well the
problem is they're coming from a
centralized
and I reject the idea that it's like
nope even if there's a good doctor it's
too expensive that's not true it's just
hard life is hard you do you are not
entitled to anything you do not have the
right to walk into a city and be like I
demand the doctor do things perfectly
it's not how reality works you can hire
a security guard you can hire a cop and
then that cop runs away from the mass
shooting event against true because a
cop and an attorney they take an oath to
you know an oath the world is not a
rigid mathematical system it is a system
of people infallibility a cop can fail
at his job and then yusu a doctor can
fail at his job and then you sue you as
an individual have the responsibility
responsibility to make sure you are
doing everything you require and it's to
me the point is this I guarantee you if
you walk into a random clinic and say
Doc whatever you say is law you will end
up with problems but if you read some
reviews online do some research let me
tell you a story I got prescribed in
antibiotic once and it had a joint
issues were associated with it I said I
will I looked up online what this was I
won't take it I skateboard and they said
okay
and then I said I read online about this
alternative treatment they said okay and
they handed me my prescription if you
don't do any of that and bad things
happens it's not because doctors are bad
it's because you don't take
responsibility for your own life but
sometimes the the the data they have is
wrong and then people are hooked into a
system that they don't really it's like
a heroin addict trying to get a heroin
addict to realize that they're in a bad
place so you need from the outside be
like a white nighting for these people
that are stuck like or what about this
real quick what about a cancer patient
that's dying that can't get access to
opioids because we're having such a
fentanyl crisis to a patient that
actually needs it so this is like a
leftist view that we should be able to
give everyone everything but I'm talking
access I'm not talking about it for free
but if it doesn't exist I'm sorry you
can't have it I would like to fly but I
don't have a jet pack no but I'm talking
about have you noticed now doctors will
not prescribe opioids to people that are
actually in pain because they do not
want to get in trouble because they're
such an overview that's a good thing but
what about the cancer patient that is in
actual pain that's not going to abuse
the pills I don't think you're entitled
to any of these I don't understand I
don't I don't think the cancer patient
should be entitled to pain medication
and no absolutely not I do not think
anyone is entitled to just be given
things that just makes no sense to me if
it doesn't exist you can't have it I'll
tell you this wouldn't they be entitled
to a cure for their cancer no because we
don't have that but I'm talking about if
somebody's in pain and we have a cheap
uh thing that'll fix their pain I think
that they should be able to have access
to it instead doctors are saying no we
can't because you know what a few years
ago we over prescribed Oxycontin and
then we got in trouble and so now we
can't actually give people with pain
pain medicine I'm sorry oopsie poopsie
the system the system is imperfect find
a better doctor this is also why the I
don't know if you guys saw uh the World
Health Organization just classified
aspartame as a possible carcinogen and
that's another thing we need to talk
about the level of cancer in young
people now is at the highest levels it's
ever been so we're talking about autism
earlier like you were talking about all
these different factors that could
happen in the 80s the amount of
aspartame the pregnant mothers
soda I'm getting cancer right now
aspartame I've been beating the drum
about how nasty this stuff is for for
about a decade there's so few studies on
this thing aspartame well they kept on
declining it when we originally tried to
get approved Donald Rumsfeld it was uh
Reagan put Rumsfeld in with this uh and
got it with like a they wouldn't vote to
make it a food because it was like I
don't know if they use it as rat poison
or something in the 60s and then when
Reagan got in it was like the day he got
into office he he stacked this five-man
panel and then they they made it legal I
think it's a little bit ridiculous
though that they're they're coming out
oh aspartame causes cancer first of all
we knew that second of all it's I think
it's just kind of
signaling like look guys don't worry
we'll tell you if something's bad for
you meanwhile the FDA just approved
lab-grown me like give me a break in the
same breath that they're approving
lab-grown meat they're like oh by the
way Diet Coke might cause cancer took
him 40 years to say that I want to
aspartame might be cancerous 40 years
what else are they not saying we got to
go to we gotta go to super chats so I'll
I'll start by reading two recent ones
and then we'll go back to the thing I
could normally do and uh Jason Hutchison
says Tim just went full Ludwig von mises
you're all a bunch of socialists and
it's awesome I stand with them on this
however Doc Holliday says Alex is Right
docs are pushes for big Pharma and
Ashley is hot AF
so you know and then uh doc Hut said Tim
failing miserably this is embarrassing
you are wrong I am right the fact is it
doesn't matter if docs are corrupt you
are not entitled to a system that works
as you want it to be unless you work to
build it if it is truth and reality that
most doctors feel for big Pharma and we
all accept that it is incumbent upon you
to find someone you trust to prescribe
you medication and if you simply go nope
no such thing exists then you are
entitled to nothing I can I can kind of
be your argument right now uh have you
ever heard of Nigeria yes I had the
lowest levels of covet yeah right how
would you compare their medical system
to ours would you say that theirs is
better or worse than ours I don't know
well I would say that it's worse right
why why would you say that well let's
just because the infrastructure the
schools that I think that do you
actually know about their infrastructure
well I know that we have more top
universities in America than Africa when
it comes to medical school so that so my
point is but let's get to the point
let's get to the point I think because
it had less medical supplies and
probably less medical infrastructure did
better with the pandemic than the
country that had access to ever a lot of
assumptions were just made that I can't
I can't
look up Nigeria's coverage rates yes so
why was Nigeria with less medical
infrastructure able to do you know they
have less medical infrastructure for a
fact
Google you and I both know this look we
can be cute no no no no no you know the
United States has a better better excuse
me you know for a fact the United States
is a better medical system than Nigeria
the whole thing was corrupt and doctors
are prescribing bad things to people I
don't know what you're saying life
expectancy in Nigeria is 52 years 54
years does that include infant mortality
maybe okay I don't know anything about
Nigeria the point I was going to make
was it is reasonable to assume their
medical system is much much worse than
ours but I just don't handle the pain
and half of the population I don't know
that so it's like dude says things about
country I don't know anything about but
what I'm saying is less medical
intervention in that country let's just
let's agree that there was less medical
intervention in that I don't know that
there might have been
the reason it's just for hypotheticals
let's just assume that I never I never
do that but even if that's true I never
I never say let's choose a country I
know nothing about did no research
the country with with less medical
supplies did better during the pandemic
than the one with access to every single
medical supply and medical expert in the
world why is that okay they just did
less for coven not that they had some
jobs how much did Nigeria spend that's
because they did less because they did
less more people live what was there
what was that probably protocol well the
reason why I was there they had their
coveted protocol well they had what was
it I believe it was Ivermectin uh in
Nigeria they have it frequency I know
the American protocol for for code I
know exactly well in Nigeria they had to
take Ivermectin because they have
parasites in their water so they already
take it regularly so I don't know if
they had to take a different scheduling
of it because they already take it so
what was their covid protocol then I
don't know what they're so this is the
problem I don't know how you can use
them as an example if you don't even
know what they were doing I don't even
need to know them doing nothing was
still more maybe they did something
maybe they actually did though well I
would guess that they did Less in
America when it came well a gas is okay
that's how I know because I know that
they administered less vaccines sure
sure but so they did less vaccines and
they had less debt I I cannot even begin
to have a conversation if you don't know
what they did I have a general idea so I
have enough of an idea to uh form an
opinion Michael's opinion is I assume
they did a thing but I didn't know
exactly what my opinion their medical
system is not as good as America's
Medical system I think we could all
agree on that that Nigeria does not have
as good a medical system as America I
think it's reasonable to assume okay I
don't know anything about it
we had the worst pandemic in the history
and in recorded history other since what
the the whatever uh Spanish Flu Spanish
Flu in 1920 but other than that in a
country in Africa had less coveted dude
I you what what about so because they
had a because it had an insert a random
country it's not random it's not random
Uganda
and you've got to have more I don't know
what they did numbers but Africa had
lower covert rates than North America
yes my point is there is no conversation
to be had if you're going to say a thing
that I have no information one is less
doctors are better not necessarily it
could be that's insane it could be a
better diet like or just that's what I
assume they have less bad diet
um here we have a lot of plastics like
food colorings made from coal tar uh
aspartame high fructose corn syrup which
is like a Franken chemical uh and if
obesity 60 obesity rates like that's a
big part of covet was obesity maybe they
didn't have that in Africa it could be a
lack of reporting you said their medical
systems yeah
so you you can't be like I don't know
what they did no but I don't know
I know the population a big enough
discrepancy that it wasn't just because
of under this is this is the issue I'll
tell you another issue take with like
with with RFK stance he's taken the
false stance that Ivermectin was not
approved because if there was a
treatment for covid it would ruin the
vaccine emergency youth authorization
which makes literally no sense at all
right because monoclonal antibodies got
an eua as well and if Ivermectin or
hydroxychlorine worked they could give
it an eua as as well you don't need to
hard approve something to allow it to be
used off label for treatment so this
statement it would not have the the
vaccine would have affected the approval
then how come the monoclonal antibodies
didn't approve the effect of the affect
the approval for vaccines maybe because
that's in the same class as a vaccine
it's not well I don't know that to be
the case I mean okay so monoclonal
antibodies is a is a therapeutic it is
not a vaccination the reason why they're
able to not do the standard testing the
protocol
is because of the emergency and so
everyone keeps saying so if Ivermectin
would have been effective they would
have not been able to use it with an
emergency UA they could have put it
under eua the same as you're talking
about putting an ivory Mexican yeah but
they didn't want to do that because it
cost two cents and everybody can get it
because they wouldn't have benefited
financially for having them so fast so
that's why so what I said was the
argument from RFK that the reason it was
not approved is because that would end
the eua is wrong and you agree with me
right well it would have if
Ivermectin would have been given to more
people I don't think Ivermectin just is
just some cure-all for covert I just
wanted to say that okay this is my point
that that it could have held RFK was
wrong when he said that and so that
would have maybe lessened the vaccines
emergency the the position taken by RFK
and many others that Ivermectin was not
approved because it would have affected
the eua as an incorrect statement
because there were treatments approved
under eua outside of vaccines if the
argument is that it's that it couldn't
make money off it I agree yeah if it had
been approved I think that's what this
all comes down to for big Pharma is
money though Tim I think if Co if
Ivermectin had been approved not for
emergency use but actually just approved
as a functioning therapeutic then maybe
it would have disrupted the euas for the
others right and so long as monoclonal
antibodies which were exorbitantly
expensive and unavailable to the average
person yeah Ivermectin costs one cent a
pill did receive an eua then they could
have put it under e-way so the problem I
have with this is it is a false argument
and if you want to make the argument it
was because of price I I agree they
don't want to approve cheap free drugs
because big Pharma is corrupt and evil
yeah so uh yeah so here's my issue
that is logically indiscernibly true but
people get so knee-jerk defensive about
any of this they're like no rfk's right
I'm like it but there's no logic it
makes no sense the money thing makes
sense the EU I think does not but people
get mad at me like you know Tim won't
admit it he's wrong about this one no
I'm right
well think how much money they made with
just the vaccines that nobody took
oh just the mass-produced
users and then the idea the idea that we
would give no bid no liability contracts
to massive multi contracts to massive
multinational corporations and mandate
medication is psychotic yeah but that's
what's ruining the world is that we're
not run by human beings and I think I
said this last time we're being run by
multinational corporations that don't
have the ability to feel empathy when
they can buy and sell these politicians
even Donald Trump I love Donald Trump
but he's inviting the Johnson Johnson
family on stage I'm saying every
politician has a price in these
multinational corporations like Pepsi
trying to put aspartame in our soda or
whether it's Raytheon trying to sell
more tanks in the Ukraine they can
actually affect the world you and me
complaining about it can't do jack I
actually I actually think complaining
about it we do have a pretty big impact
yes on the world with the boys
the boycotts have given me hope yeah but
but it's it's you got to believe man you
got to believe but the Pentagon budget I
think they had what was it 900 billion
was unaccounted for none no no I'm
talking about just 900 900 a million was
not accounted for non-military spending
for the past year so almost I mean it
was 900 billion excuse me almost a
trillion dollars yeah because a
trillions one thousand billion it was
900 billion unaccounted for they didn't
even they didn't have a paper trail of
what that's that's been happening every
year I know but listen I'm not a
socialist but we should reallocate those
funds and help people instead of just
killing people in foreign countries
let's rate some super chats Cody Griffin
says Tim will you have RFK on and Grill
him about his wish to pass Common Sense
gun restrictions would love the debate
uh I yes I think we are talking to them
I'm not entirely sure what's going on
the idea is to have RFK on the culture
War podcast but uh we will see and
um I think it would be a really
interesting discussion as it pertains to
covid lockdowns vaccinations Etc I am I
am so in favor of RFK debating hotels I
offered one hundred thousand dollars to
a charity of hotels is choosing if you
would have that debate and I have said
right here I the staunchly disagree with
some of what RFK Jr has said a lot of it
I'm not completely you know apprised to
so he's welcome to have his opinions and
say things it is insane to me that the
one of the leading experts is refusing
to have this conversation I am not an
expert I have no problem sitting before
Alex Stein and being like no here's what
I believe and here's why I believe it
why is hotas afraid to do that
my personal thought is that he was
threatened maybe not threatened but
asked politely not to do it by some of
his compatriots in the medical industry
I don't know why other than that he
likes doing podcasts and movies and
stuff so I love it I feel like he just
knows he couldn't keep up I mean
information aside I don't think he can
be he can present as well and a debate
would open him up for that he could be
wrong so there's no point in him having
a debate because then it's like oh well
I'm having a debate because maybe you
could yeah the answer is simple he does
not believe what he says
absolutely listen and Tim I think what
you said is exactly right because once
again medical misinformation but
Peter Hotes has an autistic daughter and
he wrote a book saying that vaccines do
not cause autism that is very weird
right I'm not saying that he's not right
in that but that he it's like he's I
don't know what is he's trying to run
cover for something
you would write that book if you did
have an autistic here's why I disagree
with the vaccine causes autism crowd
okay what is your basis for that
assumption well if you look at the MMR
vaccine if you look at the scheduling of
MMR vaccine and uh dell big street did a
really good video about this called vax
and there's a time when Robert De Niro
had this playing in the Tribeca film
festival and they got it taken out do
you remember that I don't know if you
want to just tell me the basis for your
oh well of MMR vaccine well they even
did it with the scheduling of the MMR if
the measles mumps rubella if they
actually gave it to him in an older age
they had less of an occurrence of autism
and as a matter of fact this actually
was more it was the MMR scheduling even
when they had the stats saying that if
they spread it out there was less autism
they still kept the normal scheduling
and there's a whole documentary about
this called vax and it affects
boys and people of color even more so
here's the issue
if you say we've got a generation of
kids with higher rates of autism let's
look at that and then compare their
vaccinations well the numbers did and
what the big Pharma said is correlation
does not mean causation
and they said correlation does not
matter and then we have to consider
every other variable that exists in
human development and the environment I
would agree with Tim there and cernovich
talks about that a lot but we do need to
get into why
there's other Specialists because with
autism it is rising dramatically
doesn't like you got to say okay so
that's the thing is he's running cover
for it my point is
I am I I do not like conspiracy theories
I love it because what people do is
they'll they'll there's a big painting
before you and they'll look at one
portion of it and say that proves it and
I'm like listen if you want to talk
about the transgender youth issue if you
want to talk about autism rights there
are a thousand variables that need to be
assessed in this before we can say we
know for sure 5G you certainly 5G
perhaps sell us the the Advent of
cellular technology over the 90s yeah I
believe absolutely some degree of impact
on the human body and they say don't
write ionizing the womb wow so my issue
is this if we know that Plastics are
causing problems birth control in the
water seeping into the water causing
problems and these are proven we we know
that there's phthalates pcbs we uh we
have an increase in in uh vaccination
scheduling all of those things are true
I will not come out and be like but this
one thing I will say definitively did
thing I don't I don't know we need a and
this is impossible to do yeah
well it's necessarily impossible we need
a long-term study looking at children
born in the 80s in a plastic heavy
country
and children born in a country with no
plastic then we need to take a similar
data set kids born in a country with no
plastic but High vaccination rates
specifically from this brand and kids
born in countries with no plastic and no
vaccination it is very very difficult to
accurately get the information that we
need to figure out what's really going
on this is the most effective measure
and I do think no disrespect
s here but I think
autism and vaccines is counterproductive
to actually figuring out what's going on
with our kids because then they just say
oh you're just a conspiracy theorist
like you said but instead we should
demand answers it very well may be that
I think it seems that is the issue right
but until we demand answers and say hey
why is this happening why is there a
dramatic increase in kids with autism
why do we have a dramatic increase in
kids with learning disabilities I think
it's Plastics I I think we will find we
need a demand for that research I think
it could be a combination of both but I
mean listen just everybody do not listen
to me I do not want to keep on spewing
medical facts on here but everyone needs
to go watch the documentary vaxxed with
the Dell big tree and that I know Tim
I'm just saying that will have some
stats in there that you're going to say
even when they question big Pharma they
say they have to say oh well you're
right these numbers are weird and the
scheduling is different if we give them
this at a lower age they have less
autism but they say correlation does not
mean causation so I've seen the numbers
I mean I've watched documentaries or the
numbers in it whatever but my point is
these are real numbers from real
agencies and they look Us in the face
and say oh well I know you're putting
two and two together but sorry it equals
five not four yeah rather than say that
it causes everything saying it it means
contributing to yes maybe contributing
does not cause that's a very good point
final thought
and we'll read more Super chats so we
you know because we've been talking
about this it is really simple
there exists as hard as it may be
a trustworthy doctor
they exist and maybe you're right it's
99 that means you gotta make 100 phone
calls before you find them if you really
do think you want sound medical advice
you better make 100 phone calls well Tim
I'll be honest I looked at 50 different
doctors before I got my penis
enlargement and I chose the wrong one oh
and I'm paying for it every day so I'm
sorry too big too big you know he's a
clear the way all right let's read some
more uh turkey robot says thanks for the
shout out to him if you liked that
symbolism of the authoritarian regime
and silence do good you're gonna love
the rest of the series by the way that
president is based off Gavin Newsom it
may end up predicting the future it's a
really cool picture it's clearly you
know Biden stand there going ah but the
the symbol for the authoritarian regime
it's a red line and then a blue line
going up and over yeah that was
brilliant very very well done I like How
It Was Written man you guys that was
really good because you took it was
almost cliche but it it wasn't it became
a very high-powered fast action movie
within like six pages I I really like
that all right
Paul taskelo says that DeSantis video
was awful that came across to me as
anti-gay very divisive trashing Trump
because he isn't being mean enough to
gay people that is the best a dentist
can do The Descendants team is horrible
what DeSantis did in that video that I
disagree with is that he conflated the
current issue of the weird grooming of
kids with eight years ago Trump being
like hey if you're gay it's all right
yeah
it did come off a little homophobic
the video well the Santa's one I don't
like I don't like that term I don't know
if it means anything yeah I know they
call me homophobic but I'm just saying
it did seem a little bit like Trump
loves gays I don't yeah yeah I mean it's
just like the issue we have is
fun I'm not saying it was that bad but
that is the vibe again like yeah and I
put him in jail it was like first first
I heard Trump say that he would
encourage um a trans woman to use a
bathroom with other girls so I don't
know if how he still feels about that
with Caitlyn Jenner what do you say that
was a big deal when Caitlyn Jenner went
and pooped in the Trump Plaza or
whatever but uh he would let Caitlyn
Jenner go to his house so Caitlyn Jenner
is probably the one on yeah I think he
really doesn't care but once you start
to understand what is happening to kids
I don't like the way they prop up
Caitlyn let's uh let's read some more
Cain Abel says RFK Jr is a Democrat and
has stated he is willing to work with
the parties I am voting for Trump 2024.
trump for the scorched Earth policy fire
them all agreed
Dave Murdock art says culture win after
being stonewalled by Steam for 30 days
and banned in China drag the dead will
officially release 707 Pearl clutching
zombie shooter starring Zane dimash and
Uncle hotep oh wow we're taking the
space back early access Keys available
timcast want one
you wanna you wanna try that game yeah
yeah yeah send it to me on Twitter hey
let me get one too I'm a big gamer so
that sounds fun there you go tell him
PDL
let's grab some more Super chats
nibup Says Megan Kelly when she grasped
it if you think these Maga people will
vote for anyone but Trump you aren't
paying attention correct we cut the
brakes in the Trump train Maga ride or
die
it's just not at the Party politics and
The Descendants people said the same
thing they said if it's if it's Trump
they're not voting
so okay then you get get Newsome I guess
let go of the cult worship for this one
oh everybody's been talking about
Newsome who would be his running mate
Michelle Obama I think Michelle would be
the president yes she will yeah I'm just
saying I think he would be her running
mate dude it's gonna be Obama memory
joke if I could just sit in my basement
in my sweats and talk on the phone have
a front man you guys laugh and think
it's Joe Biden no no it's Michelle and
she will be president and it will be
Obama Barack running the country for
eight years from his base Barack was
just at the White House with Joe Biden
for a lunch uh earlier that's grooves I
believe so there's something going on
well you know it makes me feel like they
know each other yeah but like they give
us the impression like the bidens and
and Obama's get along no way no they
hate each other Obama said never
underestimate Joe's ability to mess
things up well and they knew that Hunter
was smoking crack for forever ago when
uh he was vice president the FBI found a
rental car with crack cocaine because he
was vlogging all of them yeah all right
allahad says Tim I love you but you're
wrong about the posting on Twitter in
Twitter you have to search to get that
type of content it's not promoted like
Google I did not say it was promoted if
you post something on Twitter is
available to the public that would be
akin to putting up a big poster in the
front window of your home yes people
have to go and find it but it is still
readily displayed to the public and you
can't do that it is a crime
is it what if you have it in like a pile
of trash out on your front lawn there's
like a picture a nude picture but it's
stacked in a big pile of papers and some
kid goes up to it and sifts through the
paper yeah that's different because if
you throw it away I think that's but but
we can we can create a million different
scenarios and ultimately it's just ask
some random guy that happens to be a
judge that's how it works that maybe
didn't even have the internet when he
was a kid yep because this is how the
law works the law is human beings who
make mistakes it is remarkable to me
especially when you see in movies where
someone will be like did you sign the
contract I did you're screwed oh that
dude that new show
um
the Black Mirror episode did you see the
Black Mirror did you watch the news did
a new season come out yeah oh
the first episode is a Black Mirror the
rest is just horror movies so I enjoyed
it it's not Black Mirror though it's
just horror movies oh it's a new kind of
show like black mirror no no it is Black
Mirror it's called black production
company the Creator wasn't comfortable
doing the dystopian stuff
the first episode there is a uh I'm not
gonna spoil the story for you if you
haven't seen you there's a woman and she
has her lawyer going over a contract and
she goes how can they do this to me and
she goes it's right here in the contract
he goes but what are you kidding that's
in there too yep well then I'll do this
nope that's in the contract as well well
gee gosh darn it I guess they got me
that's not how law works yeah you can be
like good luck enforcing that contract
there there are companies that have
non-competes in New York you go before a
judge he'll be like nah throw in the
garbage bag it's done I I've said so
yeah people don't understand that I a
judge can literally just be like nope
have a nice day they don't like being
overruled in appeals and things like
that so they tried to be correct but
it's a human being who says I don't
think the law was intending that so I
should get some judges but you know
where that's a real big deal though Tim
is where the parents getting divorced
and one parent wants to transition their
kid behind their back and it's a judge
who gets to decide right you know yeah
literally so it's you know some judge
that has nothing in you know all right
family yeah exactly he's nothing Sean
says atf's frame and receiver rule was
vacated the ATF tried to regulate the
sale of 80 receivers which aren't
Firearms by law Firearms policy
Coalition just kept bending the ATF over
a barrel does that mean that guy
uh what was this uh there are people who
got arrested over that weren't there are
they are they going to get the charges
dropped now
they they you could buy kits where it
was legally not a gun and then you could
get the parts to make and build your own
gun and they started going after people
for it so interesting
it's really two A's winning across the
board
let's grab some more Super chats
another other man says from what I know
a lot of women get put on the pill to
help with endometriosis luckily my
sister said no what is that what is it
endometriosis it's a pain rather painful
condition
um but and it helps some women it's
which if it I believe Scar Tissue
developing yeah it makes your time of
the month very painful it can cause
infertility yeah so and that that's
helpful for some women and if that's the
trade-off they want yeah I think you
have to weigh the cost what the problem
with birth control is that women aren't
effectively aren't really informed about
the cost of birth control so if you have
extreme pain because of endometriosis
maybe this is the best course of action
but if you have bad cramping because
you're not getting enough of a vitamin
and they never test your vitamin levels
then probably birth control is not worth
the risk it helps with cysts too birth
control but you know they should know
but it also is linked to an increased
ranking risk risk of cervical cancer and
breast cancer we have to weigh the risks
yes and it can't just be like oh you
might gain weight because I think that's
the biggest risk that doctors warn women
about which is not enough endometriosis
is a condition where the tissue similar
to the lining of the universe uterus
grows outside of the uterus so that's
what it is oh and that's another uh
side effect of ssris is sometimes you
overeat weight gain so that's not good
if you're depressed to get fatter all
right Tikka as Graham says while I'm for
minimizing kids watching porn jail for
posting porn on Twitter is a bit much
why not just ban the account my response
to this is I find it remarkable that our
society has eroded to the point where
that is the assessment that well it's
only people you know posting pictures of
lewdness of these activities in public
that kids can find but maybe we should
ask them to stop it's like okay if
that's your position fine but understand
20 years ago
you'd get arrested if you did something
like what if it's a kid that posts it
you get arrested and throw them a juvie
or throw them in like a full
Penitentiary like dude if you commit a
crime you get like if you don't if you
don't like the law then change the law
don't just be like we've decided not to
enforce it only here though that makes
no sense
you know the in the the interpretation
of the law is not an argument
like you know you're like okay I know
it's a law but what if this happened
what if this happened what if this
happened oh yeah because we're kind of
talking about the morality of the law
and the internet is so new so we need
new laws so I'll give you an example the
law says that you can't take pictures of
children and you know loot pictures of
children and share them so they've begun
arresting teenagers for for posting on
Snapchat
yeah even if a kid if someone under 18
sends a picture of themself to someone
they're Distributing child porn the law
does not say
not of you there's no exception for it
so they've arrested kids for this stuff
well and then judges need to and they
have said okay no the purpose of a judge
is to be like the law is not intending
to destroy the lives of children because
they're doing dumb things on the
internet
they'll get a slap on the wrist don't
post this stuff again but it's very very
different from what we're trying to stop
well in States like Massachusetts
they're trying to just totally make it
okay for peer-to-peers to send nudes to
engage in sexual intercourse with any
age I think it's like 12 or 13. yeah so
there's this girl Michelle Evans I'll
just tell the story real quick she's
actually being charged in Travis County
because she was at the protest at the
Capitol in Texas and she just took a
picture of a trans person in the
bathroom they weren't peeing they were
at the sink and because it is legal to
take a picture of a person in the
bathroom even though she didn't take it
she she uh transferred it and
transmitted it she's being charged wow
wait is that the photo where there was
no it's just it's just a trans person in
the capital in the capital the Texas
state capitol and they're just using the
sink and because there was a picture in
a bathroom even though it wasn't
pornographic it's uh she's being charged
well Michael T B says Tim you're wrong
on the doctor thing there are many dirty
doctors out there if you're not rich or
you're in an insurance plan you don't
have the choice and then Jason Hutchison
says Tim is arguing ownership of self of
mind and termination and everyone else
is going re someone should do the work
for me because I want them to you know
whose doctor I'd go to I'd go to Prince
Phillips or George soros's doctor or
Bill Gates maybe not Bill Gates but
Prince Philip he lived to what like 109
or whatever 101 wow the doctor yeah
that's whose doctor I want but he's
probably a lizard so it doesn't matter
so I like talking to doctors about
meditation just I just I can't I can't
stand defeatism
and like
if there's only one in a thousand
doctors who are good it is your
responsibility to call the Thousand
doctors so you find them ain't nobody
gonna do it for you Prince Philip was a
hundred almost 99. so pretty good yeah
man I I agree when people are scared and
they are going to doctor and they feel
like they have to make a split second
decision because their body's health is
on the line that's when I worry the most
the bad information can really screw
someone so you got to just stay calm
there's no rush
yeah because listen there are doctors
that can help you out I'm not saying
every single doctor you know wants to do
dead I don't believe that at all I'm
just saying generally these doctors
don't have
they don't have uh they're not legally
allowed to actually basically
doctor with their mind they have to
follow certain protocols and if they
don't they lose their their livelihood
so that's why I don't trust them
there were doctors in the past that
would prescribe drinking Mercury
I just say this you know I remember the
story where some kid had a genetic
disease and there was a cure for it and
it cost a million bucks so the family
sued the state being like you have to
give it to us because you know because
it exists and the state was like we
would have to get we would we don't have
the money to do something like this so
my answer is you are not entitled to any
doctor you're not entitled to a good
doctor you're not entitled to good
medical care you're entitled to what you
work hard to find and if that means
every doctor is really bad but one is
one degree better it is your
responsibility to find the doctor who's
better than Canada you're entitled to it
you're literally not though what about
entitled to fire department the
government sang you can go in and get a
service does that mean you'll get good
service
a terrible service but and so you have
no guarantee towards good health care
like if all of you broke your arm you
know you wouldn't like this is the
problem there's people that are afraid
to call an ambulance and they'll call an
Uber to go to the emergency room I don't
disagree with you right my point is
you're not actually entitled to anything
oh I get what you're saying yeah all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends uh you can follow the
show at timcastirl you can follow me at
timcast become a member at timcast.com
you want to shout anything out Alex go
right now all 30 000 Prime Time with
Alex Stein follow it now I'm gonna lose
my job at the blaze if you're not going
subscribe right now prime time please
I want to keep my job
Ashley
uh you can find me on Twitter at
Sinclair Ashley you can get my book
Elephants or not birds and you should
check out thebabylonbee.com
oh thanks Tim
I'm Hannah brimwell I'm a writer for
timcast.com it's been a fun show with
both of you you should follow at timcast
news on Twitter and Instagram and if you
want to follow me personally you can
find me on Instagram handclare.b and on
Twitter at 8 supermelo thank you so much
yes thank you guys I'm Ian cross and
that was so fun I want to do this
uncensored please please please let's do
this uncensored well to that point every
vaccine is safe and effective we just
want to make that it's awesome all about
all safe and effective uncensored where
it gets hot and heavy and real Friday I
think we're not doing an uncensored one
tonight but what I've been thinking
lately is like if we're fully uncensored
we might not get the ad Revenue but
we'll get more subscribers like 10 bucks
a month so maybe it would be wise to
just go full hog that's why we do both
yeah uh we also have Kellen to my right
yeah the uncensored ones are fun but I
feel like
we're not that spicy in general you know
maybe we are maybe we are not I'm not
anyway you follow me at Calum PDL this
one was a fun one he only said that
because I was looking at him all right
everybody thanks for hanging out it's
been a blast uh we'll be back with Clips
throughout the weekend and then we'll be
back Monday we're gonna have a really
awesome culture War show next Friday so
go to youtube.comcast don't miss it we
had a great episode today debating
um this morning again youtube.com
timcast and uh we'll see you all next
time